I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everybody. Good morning, everyone. I always say good morning. Because we're here in the morning. Because we're here in the morning. Every time I do it, Jenna gives me this look like Angela. It might not be morning for everyone else. Don't stop. Don't stop saying good morning. Should we talk about the episode? We're going to be breaking
我是珍娜·菲舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一同出演《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有当时身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。大家好。大家早安。我总是说早安。因为我们是在早晨录制。因为我们是在早晨录制。每次我这么说，珍娜都会用那种眼神看着我，仿佛在说“安吉拉”。对其他人来说可能不是早晨。别停。别停下说早安。我们该聊聊这一集了吗？我们将要剖析
down today. I would love nothing more. I found this episode hilarious. This snuck up on me. Yes, it was a sneaker upper. I absolutely loved it. You know, you look back and you think about The Office and all the sort of obvious ones come to mind. Right. But this is so incredibly good. It should be on all the lists. It should. And there was more to it that didn't make it in. That is so delicious. And I can't wait to share that. What we're talking about is broke. Season 5, episode 25, written by Charlie Grandy and directed by our very own Steve Carell. How fun was that? That was amazing. That is my fast pack number one. Oh, do it. But we should start with a summary. Oh, we should. I need
今天的剧集。我求之不得。我觉得这一集太搞笑了。这集真是出乎我的意料。对，它是个“偷袭高手”。我太喜欢它了。你知道的，回首过去，想起《办公室》时，所有那些显而易见的剧集都会浮现脑海。没错。但这集实在是太棒了。它应该进入所有的排行榜。确实应该。而且还有更多没剪进去的内容。那真是太妙了。我迫不及待地想分享。我们讨论的是《破产》。第五季第二5集，由查理·格兰迪编剧，由我们亲爱的史蒂夫·卡瑞尔执导。那有多好玩？太棒了。那是我的第一号冷知识。哦，讲讲吧。但我们应该先从剧情梗概开始。哦，我们应该的。我需要
my order. Go and order. Okay. I need to say good morning. You need to go and order. It's who we are. It's who we are. All right. The summary is exhausted from making their own deliveries. The Michael Scott Paper Company is steadily gaining clients due to their very low prices, but it turns out they're going broke in the process. Yeah. Meanwhile, Dunder Mifflin is desperate to negotiate a buyout because they have lost several important clients to Michael Scott Paper Company. But Michael has other ideas. I was so impressed and also scared by all of Michael's tactics. When he gets out of the elevator and he's like doubled over and he's like, I'm really afraid. I'm afraid I'm going to say what
我的外卖。去点餐吧。好的。我得说声早安。你得去点餐。这就是我们的风格。这就是我们的风格。好吧。梗概是：迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司因亲自送货而精疲力竭，由于价格非常低廉，他们的客户稳步增加，但结果证明他们在这一过程中快要破产了。是的。与此同时，邓德米夫林迫切希望协商收购，因为他们已经失去了几个重要客户给迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。但迈克尔另有主意。我对迈克尔的所有战术感到印象深刻，同时也感到害怕。当他从电梯里走出来时，他弯着腰说，我真的很害怕。我害怕我会说出
I'm going to say. So funny. All right. Fast pack number one. Steve Carell directed this episode. It was his first time directing the show and his first time directing in general. He was so prepared. Oh my gosh. Yes. I was so impressed with him. We talked to Randy Cordray about that and he said Steve's work ethic was incredible that he was totally prepared. He had great ideas, great energy. He said he was so respectful of every crew position. He wanted everyone's input to make the scenes better. He said Steve totally immersed himself in the prep of this episode. I loved him as a director. I have one little moment I'll share when we get there of a note he gave me that I was like totally changed the scene
我要说的话。太搞笑了。好的。第一号冷知识。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔执导了这一集。这是他第一次执导这部剧，也是他第一次执导。他准备得太充分了。噢天哪。是的。我对他的印象太深刻了。我们跟兰迪·科德雷聊过这个，他说史蒂夫的工作态度令人难以置信，他完全做好了准备。他有很棒的点子，很棒的活力。他说他对每一个剧组职位都非常尊重。他想要每个人的意见来让场景变得更好。他说史蒂夫完全沉浸在这集的筹备中。我很喜欢他作为导演。我有一个小片段要分享，等我们聊到那儿时再说，那是他给我的一个建议，我当时觉得这完全改变了
for me. Well, I traded some messages with Steve about this episode. I just wanted to know, Steve, what was that like for you to direct all of us? Because he was, I believe the first cast member to step into a directing role. Oh, I think you're right. And here's what Steve said. This is a quote. It was like being the conductor of a world-class orchestra. Everyone was so good. It was pretty easy. Aw. Well, we got a fan question from Bridget R. who said, what was it like having a main cast member direct and did it present any challenges? Well, a little bit. Because, you know, Steve couldn't watch the scene when he was performing in the scene. Right, right. And the week before you direct an episode,
那个场景对我而言的意义。好吧，我和史蒂夫就这一集交换了一些信息。我只是想知道，史蒂夫，对你来说导演我们所有人是什么感觉？因为据我所知，他是第一个担当导演角色的演员。哦，我想你是对的。以下是史蒂夫的原话。这是一个原话。这就像是指挥一个世界级的交响乐团。每个人都那么优秀。这相当容易。哇。好吧，我们收到了来自布里杰·R的粉丝提问，她说，让主要演员来导演是什么体验？这有没有带来任何挑战？嗯，有一点。因为，你知道的，史蒂夫在场景中表演时无法观看这个场景。对，对，对。而在你导演一集的头一周，
the director normally preps the episode. And that sort of involves meeting with each of the different department heads to make decisions about the locations, about the props, the wardrobe, camera setups. And this was a little tricky for Steve, because Steve spent the prior week acting in an episode. I remember he had to sort of squeeze things in like he'd be in a scene and then he would have to like hop into like a van to go location scout or Yes. Yeah. Randy said, luckily, the Michael Scott paper company storyline was such that Steve generally had a couple days off each week for when we would shoot up at Dunder Mifflin. And so he immersed himself in prep for those two days. But it's true. I would
导演通常会筹备这一集。这通常包括与各个部门负责人开会，以就外景地、道具、服装、摄像机设置做出决定。这对史蒂夫来说有点棘手，因为史蒂夫在前一周都在参演一集。我记得他不得不勉强挤出时间，就像他正在拍一个场景，然后他不得不像跳进一辆面包车去勘景，或者是的。是的。兰迪说，幸运的是，迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的剧情线使得史蒂夫通常每周有几天假，供我们在邓德米夫林拍摄时使用。所以他把这两天时间完全投入到了筹备中。但确实如此。我经常
notice there would be this van waiting outside at lunch and they would go scout a location for a half hour. Yeah. And then he'd come back and jump into scenes. Well, I also spoke with Randall Einhorn, our cinematographer, who said he remembers Steve was very focused on characters and actor performance as a director. So I guess this will come up in the note that he gave you, Angela. Yeah. But he said he was just so respectful. He was so devoid of any ego. And that's how I remember working with Steve. He just made you better naturally. He's just someone that makes everything better. Yeah. You know, you know, those people, you're like, gosh, I feel so great whenever I'm around them. I took this leadership seminar
注意到午饭时外面停着这样一辆面包车，他们会去勘景半小时。是的。然后他会回来投入到场景拍摄中。好吧，我也和我们的摄影指导兰德尔·艾恩霍恩交谈过，他说他记得史蒂夫作为导演非常关注角色和演员的表演。所以我想这会在你得到的那个建议中提到，安吉拉。是的。但他说他是如此尊重他人。他完全没有自我。这就是我记忆中和史蒂夫共事的方式。他自然而然地让你变得更好。他就是那种让一切变得更好的人。是的。你知道的，你知道那些人，你会想，天哪，每当我跟他们在一起时，我都感觉好极了。我参加过这个领导力研讨会
once and they said that a great leader is a person where like you leave your interaction with that person and you feel more confident and better and you notice yourself more that that is your goal. If you're ever in a leadership position, not for you to show off how interesting and powerful you are, but to try to empower other people. Well, that's definitely Steve. That's definitely Steve. Guys, yeah, I'm that person who went to leadership seminars on the weekends. Okay. I wasn't going to say anything. I'm that gal. I wasn't going to say anything. But as you sign me up, as you said it, I thought, oh, I would have just loved to know Jenna then. I saw this thing someone posted on Instagram, Jenna, it made me laugh so hard. I'm going
有一次，他们说伟大的领导者是这样一个人：当你与那个人结束互动离开时，你感觉更自信、更好，而且你更多地注意到了自己，这就是你的目标。如果你身处领导岗位，不是为了炫耀你有多有趣、多有力量，而是去赋能其他人。好吧，那绝对是史蒂夫。那绝对是史蒂夫。伙计们，是的，我就是那种周末去参加领导力研讨会的人。好吧。我本来什么都不想说的。我就是那个女孩。我本来什么都不想说的。但当你报名时，正如你所说，我想，哦，我当时肯定会很想认识珍娜的。我看到有人在Instagram上发了这样一条动态，珍娜，把我逗得哈哈大笑。我
to paraphrase it, but it said something like everyone in life deserves the person they cannot sit next to in a serious situation. And I just think about if I had taken that leadership class with you, we wouldn't have been able to sit next to each other. Listen, that leadership class was great because I had a really hard time finishing things. I would start projects all the time. Scripts, a one woman show. I don't even know what, even a home project. I was very good at having ideas and doing the first three steps, but I wasn't a finisher. And this leadership seminar was a little bit focused on finishing what you start. I tell you what, I finish what I start now. That's so good. I'm all about it. I'm like, there's
大致复述一下，它差不多是说，生活中的每个人都值得拥有一个在严肃场合不能坐在他们旁边的人。我只是在想，如果我和你一起上了那个领导力研讨会，我们俩绝对不能坐在一起。听着，那个领导力研讨会很棒，因为我很难把事情做完。我总是开始做项目。剧本，独角戏。我甚至不知道是什么，甚至是一个家居项目。我很擅长构思并完成前三步，但我不是个能把事情做到底的人。而这个领导力研讨会有部分重点是专注于完成你开始的事情。我告诉你吧，我现在是有始有终的。太棒了。我全身心投入。我觉得，
got to be experts out there who can teach me skills. How was I supposed to be born knowing how to do everything? I'll go to therapy. I'll go to your leadership seminar. Sign me up. All right. That's fact number two is called awards because our writer, Charlie Grandy was nominated for a writer's guild award for best screenplay of an episodic comedy for this script. And Steve Carell used this episode as his submission for the Emmys for outstanding lead actor in a comedy series. Well, I know Steve didn't win, which remember I was so mad about. I think I said a profanity and there was a camera on us. Steve never won an Emmy for his portrayal of Michael Scott. How is that sentence a thing I can
外面肯定有专家能教我技能。我怎么可能是天生就知道该怎么做一切的呢？我去接受心理治疗。我去参加你的领导力研讨会。算我一个。好吧。第二号冷知识叫做“奖项”，因为我们的编剧查理·格兰迪凭借这个剧本获得了美国编剧工会奖喜剧剧集最佳编剧提名。而史蒂夫·卡瑞尔用这一集作为他角逐艾美奖喜剧类剧集最佳男主角的参选作品。好吧，我知道史蒂夫没有获奖，还记得我当时有多生气吗。我想我爆了粗口，当时还有镜头对着我们。史蒂夫从未凭借对迈克尔·斯科特的塑造赢得艾美奖。这句话怎么可能是我能
say? I don't know. Wait, did Charlie win? Charlie didn't win either. Well, son of a... I know. You know, it's crazy. That got me thinking about how you have to submit yourself for awards. I feel like that's something not a lot of people know. We did. Yeah. And it costs money. Sometimes the network will pay for it. But I think as an actor, you pick one or two episodes that you think best represent your performance. You also pick your category. You can decide if you want to be submitted for lead or supporting. I know. I was very excited because season four of The Office, there was an article that
说出来的？我不知道。等等，查理获奖了吗？查理也没获奖。好吧，真他妈的……我知道。你知道的，这太疯狂了。这让我想到你必须自己报名参评奖项。我觉得很多人都不知道这一点。我们做过。是的。而且这要花钱。有时电视网会付钱。但我觉得作为演员，你会挑选一两个你认为最能代表你表演的剧集。你还要选择你的类别。你可以决定你是想报名主角还是配角。我知道。我非常兴奋，因为《办公室》第四季时，有一篇文章
said I was a dark horse for a nomination for supporting actress in a comedy because I had that whole great, you know, arc with sprinkles and all of that. Yes. And I was so excited. That was enough for me. I mean, I realized that like some people were able to have sort of a big machine behind them campaigning. But just the fact that this one person saw my performance, I cut out the magazine. I saved it. I totally get that, Ange. I was only nominated the one year for season two. Yeah. And occasionally, though, my name would come up on those lists. Yes. It's so exciting. Yeah.
说我是喜剧类剧集最佳女配角提名的黑马，因为我和小不点（Sprinkles）有那么多精彩的故事线等等。是的。我太兴奋了。对我来说这就够了。我的意思是，我意识到有些人能够有强大的幕后团队为他们进行宣传。但仅凭这个人看到了我的表演，我就把那期杂志剪了下来。我把它保存了下来。我完全理解，安吉拉。我只在第二季时获得过那一次提名。是的。不过，偶尔我的名字也会出现在那些名单上。是的。太令人兴奋了。是的。
What's your fast fact number three? Fast fact number three is called Time to Make the Donuts. Do I get a donut? Did you make donuts? No, I wish I had, though. I know you love a donut. I do. I should have known. I can't say donut and not provide you with a donut. You literally said it's time to make the donuts. Oh, no. This is not a Scotch and Splenda. I know. You got me thinking it's a Scotch and Splenda moment. No. This is a little mini deep dive that I found incredibly charming based on the fact
你的第三号冷知识是什么？第三号冷知识叫做“该做甜甜圈了”。我有甜甜圈吗？你做甜甜圈了吗？没有，不过我希望我有。我知道你很喜欢甜甜圈。我是。我本该想到的。我不能说甜甜圈却不给你提供一个甜甜圈。你刚才字面意思上说了“是时候做甜甜圈了”。哦，不。这不是苏格兰威士忌加代糖（Scotch and Splenda）。我知道。你让我以为这是一个苏格兰威士忌加代糖的时刻。不是的。这是一个微型深入剖析，我发现它极其迷人，其依据是
that Michael says it's time to make the donuts. Oh, the expression. Yes. Do you remember that commercial? It was from the 80s. It actually ran from 1981 all the way to 1997, and it was for Dunkin' Donuts. Do you remember it? Well, I was overseas until 84. Okay. This, by the way, is the thing my husband loves to tease me about.
迈克尔说“是时候做甜甜圈了”。哦，这个表达。是的。你还记得那个广告吗？那是80年代的。它实际上从1981年一直播到1997年，是为唐恩都乐（Dunkin' Donuts）拍的。你还记得吗？嗯，我直到84年都在海外。好吧，顺便说一句，这是我丈夫最喜欢拿来取笑我的事。
He said, Ange, you can't say you were in Indonesia for everything, okay? But there's some pop culture that's lost on you. Yes. Okay. Well, I grew up without television. Is that crazy? Until I was a teenager. Wow. I know. And then you wound up on television. And then I was obsessed with television.
他说，安吉拉，你不能说你什么都在印度尼西亚经历过，好吧？但有些流行文化你确实错过了。是的。好吧，我在没有电视的环境中长大。是不是很疯狂？直到我成为青少年。哇。我知道。然后你竟然上了电视。然后我就对电视着迷了。
I bet. It's like the kid that their parents don't let them have any sweets, and then they come to your house and they raid your pantry. Yeah. I became obsessed with television. Well, let me bring you up to speed. Okay. Fred the Baker was a character played by actor Michael Vail
我敢打赌。就像那些父母不让他们吃任何甜食的小孩，然后他们来到你家，洗劫了你的食品储藏室。是的。我对电视着迷了。好吧，让我给你补补课。好吧。烘焙师弗雷德（Fred the Baker）是演员迈克尔·维尔（Michael Vail）
in these Dunkin' Donut commercials. Okay. And he was known for his catchphrase, Time to Make the Donuts. So it would just be him, like all day, coming in and out of his door, saying, Time to Make the Donuts. I actually have an audio clip of it. Oh, I need to hear it. Time to make the donuts.
在这些唐恩都乐广告中扮演的角色。好的。他以他的口头禅“是时候做甜甜圈了”（Time to Make the Donuts）而闻名。所以剧情基本上就是他，一整天都在进出他的门，说：“是时候做甜甜圈了。”我实际上有一段它的音频剪辑。哦，我得听听。是时候做甜甜圈了。
Dunkin' Donuts are always fresh. I made the donuts. We make them at least twice every day. Time to make the donuts. Not a few kinds like supermarkets. Donuts. Time to make the donuts. But up to 52 varieties.
唐恩都乐永远新鲜。我做了甜甜圈。我们每天至少做两次。是时候做甜甜圈了。不像超市里只有几种。甜甜圈。是时候做甜甜圈了。而是多达52个品种。
The donuts. Mm-hmm. Time to make the donuts. I made the donuts. Dunkin' Donuts up to 52 varieties fresh day and night. No supermarket can say that. So Fred the Baker had to make all those donuts, lady. I have so many questions, because I could only hear it and not see it.
甜甜圈。嗯哼。是时候做甜甜圈了。我做了甜甜圈。唐恩都乐多达52个品种，日夜新鲜。没有超市能这么说。所以烘焙师弗雷德必须做所有那些甜甜圈，女士。我有好多问题，因为我只能听到它却看不到。
It sounds like he's getting really tired. He's tired? He's making donuts in the rain? Time to make the donuts. Because he's always making the donuts. Yeah. Well, this commercial was named one of the five best commercials of the 80s by the Television Bureau of Advertising.
听起来他好像真的很累。他累了？他在雨里做甜甜圈？是时候做甜甜圈了。因为他总是在做甜甜圈。是的。嗯，这个广告被电视广告局（Television Bureau of Advertising）评为80年代五大最佳广告之一。
Fred the Baker was so popular that when Dunkin' Donuts decided to finally retire this character, they surveyed customers to see how they might react. Well, customers said they would let Fred retire, but only if Fred the character was treated like an honored friend and employee. So Dunkin' Donuts created an official retirement celebration for him, which included a parade in Boston and a free donut day. They served over 6 million customers. It was September 22, 1997.
烘焙师弗雷德是如此受欢迎，以至于当唐恩都乐决定最终让这个角色退休时，他们调查了客户，看看他们的反应会如何。嗯，客户表示他们会让弗雷德退休，但前提是必须像对待受人尊敬的朋友和员工那样对待弗雷德这个角色。于是唐恩都乐为他举办了一场官方退休庆典，其中包括在波士顿的游行和一个免费甜甜圈日。他们服务了超过600万名客户。那是1997年9月22日。
Wow. But listen to this. After the actor who played Fred the Baker after Michael Vail died in December of 2005, Dunkin' Donuts ran a commercial celebrating him that included like an in-memory of. And today, the catchphrase, Time to Make the Donuts, is printed on the side of all Dunkin' Donut boxes in memory of Michael and his character of Fred the Baker. So if you get a box of Dunkin' Donuts and you see that on the side, that's why. That's so sweet.
哇。但听这个。在饰演烘焙师弗雷德的演员迈克尔·维尔于2005年12月去世后，唐恩都乐播放了一则纪念他的广告，其中包含了诸如“缅怀”之类的内容。如今，口头禅“是时候做甜甜圈了”被印在所有唐恩都乐纸盒的侧面，以纪念迈克尔和他的烘焙师弗雷德这个角色。所以如果你拿到一盒唐恩都乐，看到侧面有这个，这就是原因。太暖心了。
You know, I think Dunkin' Donuts was more of an East Coast chain for a long time. Because I know whenever I flew to New York, I got very excited because there was a Dunkin' Donuts by baggage claim, and I would always go get a donut while I waited for my suitcase. Yeah. We had Dunkin' Donuts in St. Louis growing up, and my dad would go every Sunday, and I always wanted that strawberry iced. I love that one. That was my favorite.
你知道，我觉得唐恩都乐很长一段时间里更多是东海岸的连锁店。因为我知道每当我飞往纽约时我都超级兴奋，因为行李提取处旁边就有一家唐恩都乐，我总会去买个甜甜圈，一边等行李一边吃。是的。我从小在圣路易斯就有唐恩都乐，我爸爸每个星期天都会去，我总是想要那个草莓糖霜的。我喜欢那个。那是我的最我也很喜欢那个。
I love that one, too. Now during the office, there was no Dunkin' Donuts on the West Coast, and John Krasinski had this idea that he wanted to open up the first Dunkin' Donuts in L.A. Did he really? Yes. He was really into this for a while, and he tried to get Conan O'Brien to go in on it with him. Oh my God.
现在在《办公室》拍摄期间，西海岸没有唐恩都乐，约翰·卡拉辛斯基有个想法，他想在洛杉矶开第一家唐恩都乐。真的吗？是的。他有一段时间对这个非常热衷，他还试图拉着柯南·奥布莱恩和他一起合伙。哦，天哪。
This was a whole thing. Could you imagine if Conan and John owned a Dunkin' Donuts? That was the plan. I don't know why it fell apart, or if this was just like a daydream, but he talked about it all the time. He wanted to open a Dunkin' Donuts franchise in L.A. You know what? Now they're here, and whenever I pass by them, I wonder, is John like super pissed because
这可是一件大事。你能想象如果柯南和约翰拥有一家唐恩都乐吗？这就是计划。我不知道为什么后来黄了，或者这是否只是像个白日梦，但他一直在谈论这件事。他想在洛杉矶开一家唐恩都乐加盟店。你知道吗？现在它们开到这儿了，每当我路过它们时，我都在想，约翰是不是超级生气，因为
he had that idea. That was John Krasinski's idea. To bring it to the West Coast. Yes. Well, that's all I got for Fast Facts, lady. Well, I found them delightful, and now I want a donut. Sorry, I really should have brought some Dunkin' Donuts in. Clearly.
那是他的主意。那是约翰·卡拉辛斯基的主意。把它带到西海岸。是的。好吧，关于冷知识我就知道这么多啦，女士。嗯，我觉得它们太棒了，现在我想吃个甜甜圈。抱歉，我真的应该带一些唐恩都乐来的。显然。
What was I thinking? I think we should go to break, and we'll come back and get into this episode. I love it. All right, we're back. This episode opens with Pam, Michael, and Ryan making paper deliveries. Yeah. Incidentally, I found out the working title for this episode was Delivery Day. Yes.
我当时在想什么？我觉得我们应该去休息一下，然后回来继续聊这一集。我喜欢。好的，我们回来了。这一集的开场是帕姆、迈克尔和瑞恩在送纸。是的。顺便说一句，我发现这一集的暂定剧名叫《送货日》。是的。
Thank you, Randy, with those nuggets. Well, you know what, Michael starts the day at 4.30 in the morning with a prank. He pulls up to get Ryan, and then as Ryan gets in, he pulls up forward, and he pulls forward, and Ryan just like, oh, Jenna, that would drive me crazy. Yeah. I don't need people that peppy that early. No. It's too peppy.
谢谢你，兰迪，提供了这些干货。嗯，你知道吗，迈克尔在清晨4点30分以一个恶作剧开始了一天。他把车开过去接瑞恩，然后当瑞恩上车时，他把车往前开，往前开，而瑞恩只是——哦，珍娜，这会把我逼疯的。是的。我不需要大清早就这么亢奋的人。不。太亢奋了。
We got a fan question from Tyler B, who said this, my friend and I have watched the opening scene with Michael inching the delivery van forward while Ryan tries to get in over and over. At 46 seconds, we cannot figure out if Michael says, I lied or denied to Ryan. It's denied. He says the captions say denied, but I'm not convinced because it almost sounds like Delied, do you know? What did it say?
我们收到了泰勒·B的粉丝提问，他是这么说的：我和我的朋友一遍又-遍地看开场镜头，迈克尔把送货车一点点往前挪，而瑞恩试图上车。在第46秒，我们怎么也琢磨不透迈克尔对瑞恩说的是“我撒谎了（I lied）”还是“我拒绝了（denied）”。是“denied”（拒绝了）。他说字幕上写的是“denied”，但我不太确信，因为它听起来几乎像是“Delied”，你知道吗？它说的是什么？
It was not a scripted moment. Oh, of course not. Of course they were playing around a little bit. I hear I lied, but I hear Steve's, Steve has this funny delivery he does sometimes where he like laughs at the beginning of a line. And he'll hold out a vowel. So I hear Delied, meaning like the D is like part of his laugh. Well, gosh, I just think I need to hear it.
那不是剧本里的时刻。哦，当然不是。当然他们是在瞎胡闹。我听到的是“I lied”，但我听到史蒂夫的——史蒂夫有时候有一种很好笑的发音方式，他会在一句台词开头时笑出声。他会拖长一个元音。所以我听到的是“Delied”，意思是那个D听起来像是他笑声的一部分。天哪，我觉得我非得听听不可。
I need to hear it. And then I'm going to decide what I hear and I think we should put a poll in our office ladies pod stories. I agree. Delied. It's I lied. He's like, I lied. I got to hear it again.
我得听听。然后我要决定我听到的是什么，我觉得我们应该在“Office Ladies”播客动态里发个投票。我同意。“Delied”。是“I lied”。他说的是“I lied”。我得再听一遍。
I got to hear it again. Delied. Oh my gosh, it's definitely I lied because he's saying I won't do it again. Yes. I'm laughing. It's I lied. It's not denied. The subtitles are wrong.
我得再听一遍。“Delied”。哦天哪，绝对是“I lied”，因为他说的是“我不会再犯了”。是的。我在笑。是“I lied”。不是“denied”。字幕弄错了。
Completely. It's definitely not denied, but it is like I lied. Yeah. Yeah. It's a little laugh. It's a little bit of a catch at the top. It's a little bit of a Delied. Tyler, I hope that that has helped you guys.
完全弄错了。绝对不是“denied”，但听起来确实像“I lied”。是的。是的。开头有个小笑声。开头有点儿卡壳。有点儿像“Delied”。泰勒，我希望这能帮到你们。
We took that on and we took it very seriously. We did. We did. Well, then Michael's got to go get Pam. He pulls outside and lays on the horn. Did you ever have a friend like that? I carpooled with a friend in high school who would lay on the horn and my dad was like, all right, you got to tell her.
我们重视了这个事，而且我们非常认真地对待它。我们确实很认真。好吧，接着迈克尔要去接帕姆。他把车停在外面狂按喇叭。你以前有过这样的朋友吗？我在高中时和朋友拼车，她会按喇叭，我爸爸就说，好了，你得去跟她说说。
Yes. None of that. It's early. Yes. That was our carpool. You would go in the person's driveway and you want to just give it like a bup, bup, bup, bup. Yeah.
是的。别来这套。太早了。是的。那是我们的拼车经历。你会把车开到别人家车道上，你只想轻轻按一下“叭，叭，叭，叭”。是的。
Not a bang, bang. Exactly. We got a lot of fan mail about these pickup scenes. One person said when Michael beeps the horn of the van, you can see the top right corner of the neighbor's light turning on. They really like that detail. People also wanted to know, were these scenes really recorded at 4.30 and 5.00 in the morning? No.
不是“砰，砰”。没错。我们收到了很多关于这些接送场景的粉丝来信。一个人说，当迈克尔按响面包车的喇叭时，你可以看到邻居家的灯右上角亮了起来。他们真的很喜欢这个细节。人们还想知道，这些场景真的是在清晨4点30分和5点录制的吗？没有。
We shot these at night. What we would do is we would shoot all day at the studio and then we would pack up and drive out to these locations to do the early morning shots. So it was actually just evening. I checked in with Randy to refresh my memory. He said we had to do this over two days because we never wanted to shoot too late into the evening because then we'd have to start later the next morning because you have to give the crew and the cast their turnaround.
我们是晚上拍的。我们的做法是，白天一整天在片场拍摄，然后收拾行李，驱车前往这些外景地拍摄清晨的镜头。所以其实只是傍晚。我跟兰迪核对了一下以唤醒我的记忆。他说我们必须花两天时间来拍这个，因为我们从来不想拍摄到太晚，因为那样的话第二天我们就得更晚开工，因为你得给剧组和演员他们的休息时间（turnaround）。
And then you guys, that becomes a domino effect. Then every day starts later and later and then you get into one of those what we call a Friday day situation. Friday. Friday. Frat. Frider. Frat.
然后你们就会发现，这就成了一个多米诺骨牌效应。接着每一天开工都越来越晚，然后你就会陷入我们所说的“周五白昼日”（Friday day）状况。周五。周五。Frat。Frider。Frat。
Frat. Like sat today, but fruh from Friday. So fratter day. Well, I've always called it frider day because you go F-R-I-D and then you go into Saturday. You I believe would be the only one who's saying frider day. Everyone else is saying fratter day? In the biz. Well guys, is it any surprise that I didn't sing it wrong?
Frat。就像星期六（Saturday），但从周五（Friday）变来，所以叫Fratter day。嗯，我一直叫它Frider day，因为你是F-R-I-D，然后过渡到星期六（Saturday）。我想你大概是唯一一个叫它Frider day的人吧。其他人都在叫Fratter day？在圈内。好吧，伙计们，我没有唱错这首歌，这难道很让人意外吗？
I guess I could stand corrected, but I feel pretty confident. I will be texting a few of our friends when we wrap. All right. Why don't you tell us more about how you shot these scenes? You obviously did one day was the Ryan pickup and then the next day was like the Pam pickup. No. What? One day was at Michael's condo.
我想我可能会被纠正，但我感觉挺有信心的。等我们收工后我会给我们的几个朋友发短信。好的。你为什么不跟我们多讲讲你是怎么拍这些场景的呢？显然有一天是接瑞恩，然后第二天是接帕姆。不对。什么？有一天是在迈克尔的公寓。
Okay. You know, at the opening shot. At the beginning, right? The other night we did both Ryan's house and Jim and Pam's house because the location for Ryan's house was just a few houses down the block from Jim and Pam's house on Calvert Street in Van Nuys. And the people who live next to the house that we use for Jim and Pam's house, let us put a PA up in their bedroom to flip on the light switch.
好吧。你知道的，在开场镜头里。在开头，对吧？另一个晚上我们同时拍了瑞恩家和吉姆与帕姆的家，因为瑞恩家的外景地就在范奈司卡尔弗街（Calvert Street）上吉姆和帕姆家往下走几栋房子的距离。而我们用作吉姆和帕姆家隔壁的住户，让我们把一个制作助理（PA）安排在他们的卧室里来开关电灯开关。
To flip on the light. They were very good sports, Randy said. And that's not all. Angela, I also got a ton of fan questions about the van because Pam has that talking head where she says they got it at a used car lot and they think that it says, alleluia church of Scranton in Korean on the side of the van. People wanted to know what did it really say? It said alleluia church of Scranton in Korean.
来开关电灯。兰迪说他们非常配合。不仅如此。安吉拉，我还收到了大量关于面包车的粉丝提问，因为帕姆有一段单人访谈，她说他们是从二手车行买的，他们认为车身上用韩语写着“斯克兰顿哈利路亚教会”（Alleluia Church of Scranton）。人们想知道它实际上写的是什么？上面用韩语写的就是“斯克兰顿哈利路亚教会”。
Our graphics artist, Michael Marcus designed the logo and they had it made into a large like stick on decal that they put on the side of the van. So it really did say that. I love that because I love our shows attention to detail. I have a question for you, Jenna. Yes. In the next beat of this cold open, you're like, gosh, I could really use some coffee and Michael's like milk and sugar and you're like, yes, thank you.
我们的美术平面设计师迈克尔·马库斯设计了这个标志，他们把它做成了一个大大的贴纸贴在面包车侧面。所以上面真的写的是这个。我很喜欢这个，因为我喜欢我们这部剧对细节的关注。我有个问题要问你，珍娜。是的。在这个冷开场的下一个节拍中，你说，天哪，我真的很需要咖啡，然后迈克尔说加奶和糖，你说，好的，谢谢你。
And you take a big ol' swig and it's actually milk and sugar. And Michael says he drinks it every morning. Yeah. Would you really drink? It was just water. Please say it was just water. It was water. Thank goodness.
然后你狠狠地喝了一大口，其实里面就是奶和糖。迈克尔说他每天早晨都喝。是的。你真的会喝吗？其实只是水。求求你告诉我那只是水。是水。谢天谢地。
But I really sold it. You did. When I was rewatching this episode, I watched that moment and I was like, that's good acting. I did a good job. It is good acting because I should put that on my Emmy submission. You should. Because when I watched it, I thought, I wonder if Jenna was like, you can put milk and sugar so I react honestly or something, if you got kind of method, but you did what I did about
但我演得真的很投入。你确实很投入。当我重温这一集时，我看了那个时刻，心想，这演技真好。我表现得很好。这确实是好演技，因为我应该把它放到我的艾美奖参选作品里。你应该的。因为当我观看时，我想，我不知道珍娜是不是那种会说“你可以放真的奶和糖，这样我的反应才真实”之类的话，如果你变得有点注重体验派的话，但你做的事跟我做的是一样的——
running. Yeah. I was like, I'll just fake it. Fake it. I'm an actor. I can do it. You can do it. And I did.
关于跑步。是的。我当时想，我就假装一下。假装就行。我是个演员。我能做到。你能做到。而我做到了。
And you sold it. So now Pam and Ryan are going to be unloading the paper and I want to say a few things. Did you notice that I'm wearing a pencil skirt? I did. Did you see what the boys are wearing? I did. Well, Pam is wearing a hoodie and sneakers, but a pencil skirt. And I think with pantyhose at 4.30 in the morning.
而且你演得很逼真。所以现在帕姆和瑞恩要去卸纸了，我想说几件事。你们有没有注意到我穿着一条铅笔裙？我注意到了。你们看到男孩们穿的是什么了吗？我注意到了。嗯，帕姆穿着连帽衫和运动鞋，但却穿着一条铅笔裙。而且我觉得在清晨4点30分还穿着连丝袜。
Yes. To unload paper out of a van. Yes. Pam. Hmm. RNBC executives. Correct. I guess that note about Pam being in a pencil skirt.
是的。从面包车上卸纸。是的。帕姆。嗯。NBC高管们。没错。我想关于帕姆穿着铅笔裙的那条意见。
Wow. That really carries. Oh, I want to tell you also in this scene, a woman tries to get on the van. Yes. And the woman who gets on the bus was played by Clara Soyoung and the person who played the warehouse supervisor who's with Michael was played by Isabelle Hubman. And I remember both of them were super awesome because we actually shot this really early in the morning.
哇。真的很有效果。哦，我还想告诉你，在这场戏里，一个女人试图上车。是的。上车的那个女人由克拉拉·素英（Clara Soyoung）饰演，而和迈克尔在一起的仓库主管则由伊莎贝尔·胡布曼（Isabelle Hubman）饰演。我记得他们两个都超级棒，因为我们实际上是在清晨非常早的时候拍的。
This one you did do early. We did. We got there. Oh my gosh. We were shooting by 6.45. Wow. And so I remember like we were all legitimately tired, but we also got finished really quickly. So it was fun.
这场戏你们确实拍得很早。我们确实很早。我们到了。哦，天哪。我们6点45分就在拍了。哇。所以我记得我们当时都累得够呛，但我们也很快就拍完了。所以很有趣。
Well, you know, Jenna, this was not the original cold open for the episode. Really? Truly. Tell me more. I will. Here was the original cold open. This is how the cold open was in the shooting draft. It is the Dundermifflin office parking lot.
嗯，你知道的，珍娜，这并不是这集最初的冷场开场。真的吗？真的。多跟我说说。好的。最初的冷场开场是这样的。拍摄剧本里的冷场开场是这样的。地点是邓德米夫林办公室的停车场。
Early morning we hear a screech in the parking lot. The camera pushes in to find Michael with wet hair frantically parking and sort of running in. And he says, I'm late. I'm late. I'm late. Barges into the Dundermifflin bullpen, goes right into his office, and he's like, sorry, sorry, sorry, everyone.
清晨，我们听到停车场传来一声刺耳的刹车声。镜头推进，发现迈克尔湿着头发，慌乱地停车，然后一路小跑进来。他说，我迟到了。我迟到了。我迟到了。他冲进邓德米夫林的员工办公区，径直走进他的办公室，嘴里念叨着，对不起，对不起，对不起，各位。
I'm overslept. Totally unexcusable. And he goes in his office and shuts the door. Aaron and the rest of the office are very confused. Jim looks to camera and he says, this is a surprise. Michael's almost never late, and he hasn't worked here in four weeks. And then there's this brief scene between Jim and Michael, where Jim says, hey, uh, what are you doing here?
我睡过头了。完全不可原谅。然后他走进办公室，关上了门。艾琳和办公室的其他人都非常困惑。吉姆看着镜头说，这可真是个惊喜。迈克尔几乎从不迟到，而且他已经四周没在这儿上班了。接着，吉姆和迈克尔之间有一场简短的戏，吉姆说，嘿，呃，你来这儿干什么？
And Michael's like, oh, I owe everyone a huge apology. Did anyone notice I was late? And Jim says, I think they're just surprised you came at all. And then this plays out with Charles coming in and Aaron going, that's him. Like he's some intruder, right? And then Michael realizes he's really embarrassed and he leaves and Aaron's like, was I supposed to stop him? He seems so confident.
迈克尔则说，哦，我欠大家一个巨大的道歉。有人注意到我迟到了吗？吉姆说，我想他们只是惊讶你居然会来。然后，这一幕继续发展，查尔斯走了进来，艾琳喊道，就是他。就像他是个什么入侵者一样，对吧？然后迈克尔意识到自己非常尴尬，于是离开了，艾琳则说，我是不是该拦住他？他看起来那么自信。
And then there's this last little moment where Michael goes downstairs to the Michael Scott paper company and he's like, I'm sorry, I'm late, but only Pam is there, but Ryan is late. It's so funny, Randy told us that there were a ton of deleted scenes from this episode. And I bet what they did was they cut this cold open and they made what would have been the top of this episode a cold open because this is not a standalone cold open. This relates to the rest of the episode. It's, you know, deliveries and Michael Scott paper company.
接着是最后一个小片段，迈克尔下楼去了迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司，他说，对不起，我迟到了，但里面只有帕姆一个人，而瑞恩迟到了。太搞笑鸟，兰迪告诉我们这集有很多被删减的片段。我敢说他们做的是剪掉了这个冷场开场，然后把原本会放在这集开头的片段剪成了冷场开场，因为这不是一个独立的冷场开场。这与本集的其余部分有关。你知道的，送货和迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司。
And so that's really interesting. They must have had to do that for time to squeeze more stuff in. There was a lot in the shooting draft that did not make it in. Wow. So as this episode opens, Charles Minor is going to walk into the Dunder Mifflin bullpen and announced that they have now lost 10 clients to Michael Scott paper company. Yeah. That's a huge dent in their business.
所以这真的很有趣。他们一定是为了腾出时间塞进更多内容才这么做的。拍摄剧本里有很多内容最后都没能保留下来。哇。所以这集一开场，查尔斯·迈纳就要走进邓德米夫林员工办公区，宣布他们现在已经有10个客户被迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司抢走了。对啊。这对他们的业务来说是个巨大的打击。
It really is Charles is going to have a talking head where he says he does not know what to do to inspire people and the camera is going to pull back. You're going to see Dwight hovering over his shoulder. I just want to point out that Dwight is still wearing his long sleeve white shirts with the sleeves that are too short because you can see his full watch. It is exposed on his wrist. His sleeves are too short. It's official.
确实如此。查尔斯会有一个对着镜头的独白，说他不知道该如何激励大家，然后镜头拉远。你会看到德怀特悬在他的肩膀上方。我只想指出，德怀特穿的依然是那种长袖白衬衫，袖子短得过分，因为你能看到他的手表完全露出来了。它暴露在他的手腕上。他的袖子太短了。实锤了。
We agree with you, Jenna. We agree. His sleeves are too short. Okay. Thank you. But before this talking head ends, Angela is going to enter the room to talk about these expense reports. Yes.
我们赞同你，珍娜，我们赞同。他的袖子太短了。好吧。谢谢你。但在这次独白结束之前，安吉拉将走进房间来谈论这些费用报销单。是的。
And all right. This is the scene I was talking about earlier where Steve gave me a note that changed how I delivered this line. And it was so fun for me to rewatch and remember Angela comes in and she goes, Charles, I got your memo about the expense reports. Thank you. And Steve was like, what if almost in Angela's mind, this was like a personal memo to her. Like he sees her, right?
然后，好吧。这就是我之前提到的那场戏，史蒂夫给了我一个建议，改变了我台词的表达方式。我重温并回忆起来时觉得太有趣了：安吉拉走进来，说道，查尔斯，我收到了你关于费用报销单的备忘录。谢谢。史蒂夫当时就说，如果站在安吉拉的角度，几乎会觉得这就像是一份给她个人的备忘录呢。就像他注意到了她，对吧？
He understands how much these expense reports have meant to her over the years and how Michael just never cared about them. So he was like, great note. Great note. What if this is like personal? So that's why I walked in and I was like, Charles, I got your memo about the expense reports. Thank you.
他理解这些费用报销单这些年对她意味着什么，而迈克尔却从来不在乎这些。所以他当时就说，好建议。真是个好建议。如果这感觉很私人呢？所以这就是为什么我走进去时说，查尔斯，我收到了你关于费用报销单的备忘录。谢谢。
And I sort of touched my chest. Yeah. Thank you for seeing me. This starts an amazing runner, Jenna, about the expense reports. The whole entire thing got deleted for time. And I'm going to share about it. Before I play the first one, I want you to know when Angela leaves the room and Dwight says to Charles, been there, done that, that was not in the script.
我还顺势摸了摸胸口。对。谢谢你注意到我。这就引出了一条精彩的副线剧情，珍娜，关于费用报销单的。整整一段都因为时长原因被删掉了。我会跟大家分享这部分内容。在我播放第一段剪辑之前，我想让你们知道，当安吉拉离开房间，德怀特对查尔斯说“见多识广，身经百战”时，这可不是剧本里有的。
Oh, rain improvised that rain improvised that. And then immediately after the scene would have started this expense reports runner. Angela is delighted to be policing people. Here is clip number one. Stanley. Andrew. Rejected. You never had a problem with me expensive cigars before.
哦，雷恩是即兴发挥的，雷恩是即兴发挥的。然后紧接着这场戏，就会展开这个费用报销单的副线剧情。安吉拉对能够管束大家感到十分开心。这是第一段剪辑。斯坦利。安德鲁。拒绝。你以前从来没挑剔过我的雪茄报销啊。
Yes, I did. I just didn't have the power to enforce it. Phyllis, this client you take out to Alfredo's every Saturday night, wouldn't happen to be a refrigeration company, would it? Michael never cared. He said it was a perk of the job. I'm sorry. I get no joy from this.
不，我挑剔过。我只是以前没有执行这项权力的权力。菲莉丝，你每周六晚上带去阿尔弗雷多的这位客户，该不会是一家制冷公司吧？迈克尔从来不在乎。他说这是工作福利。很抱歉。我可从中找不到一丝乐趣。
All right. So on that line, on that line, I get no joy from this. I turn around and I walk away beaming with the biggest smile. And so I took a screen grab of it. It's hilarious. I'm going to put it in stories. And then right after this, there would have been back-to-back Phyllis and Angela talking heads.
好吧，就在那句台词上，在那句台词“我可从中找不到一丝乐趣”上。我转过身，带着灿烂的笑容大步走开。所以我截了一张屏。太爆笑鸟。我会把它发到快拍里。然后紧接着这一幕，本该是菲莉丝和安吉拉连续两个背靠背的独白。
And this is what Angela said in her talking head. She holds up a rejected stamp and says, I bought it for myself for my birthday. I've been waiting for a chance to use it. It came with an approved stamp, which I can't seem to find. Amazing. And then Phyllis would have had a talking head immediately after that said, that little bitch, get with the program, a free dinner here, a bottle of wine there. She's happy.
这就是安吉拉在她的独白中所说的话：她举起一枚“已拒绝”的印章说，这是我自己买给自己的生日礼物。我一直在等待机会用它。它还配了一个“已批准”的印章，不过我好像找不到了。太绝了。然后菲莉丝紧接着会有一段独白，说道，那个小贱人，识相点吧，在这儿蹭顿免费晚餐，在那儿拿瓶葡萄酒。她倒是开心了。
You take away my perks. See you later, alligator. Oh, Phyllis sass. What is that? What's see you later, alligator? I'm not sure. I don't, I don't know if you want to find out. I know.
你剥夺了我的福利。回头见，鳄鱼。哦，菲莉丝式的讽刺。那是什么？“回头见，鳄鱼”是什么意思？我不确定，我不知道你们是不是想去探个究竟。我懂。
So there was all this hullabaloo with Angela rejecting everyone's expense reports and it keeps playing out. I'll share more later. Well, next up, we're going to go down to the Michael Scott paper company where everyone is so tired. Well, they've been getting up at 4.30 in the morning every day. Ryan thinks they should get a delivery guy. Michael thinks they should just maybe build a loft for Pam in particular.
所以，安吉拉拒绝所有人的费用报销单引发了一阵鸡飞狗跳，而这还在继续上演。我稍后会分享更多。好吧，接下来，我们要去到迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司，那里每个人都累得够呛。好吧，他们每天早上4点半就得起床。瑞恩认为他们应该找个送货员。迈克尔则认为他们或许该专门给帕姆搭建一个阁楼。
Yeah, just bunk up there, Pam. Michael's like, yeah, dorm rooms have lofts. And Ryan's like, no, they don't, Michael. But did you have a loft in your dorm? Because I did. No, I had two twin beds in my dorm room. My dad built me a loft and I put my bed up high and I put my desk underneath it, just like Michael said.
对，就在那儿凑合住吧，帕姆。迈克尔就像是在说，对啊，大学宿舍都有阁楼。瑞恩则说，才没有呢，迈克尔。不过你当年的宿舍里有阁楼吗？因为我以前有。没有，我大学宿舍里只有两张单人床。我爸爸给我搭了一个阁楼，我把床放在高处，把书桌放在下面，就像迈克尔说的那样。
Well, I had friends that had that in their bedrooms growing up, but in my college, you had a roommate. Did you not have a roommate? I did have a roommate. And the- Your dad built a loft on your side of the- I had a one-room dorm room with two twin beds and a little sink in the corner. Yeah, so we had like a Jack and Jill bathroom situation.
好吧，我认识的朋友里，有人从小到大卧室里就有那个，但在我的大学里，你得有个室友。你难道没有室友吗？我确实有个室友。然后——你爸爸在你那边的空间搭了个阁楼？我住的是一个单间宿舍，里面有两张单人床和一个小水槽在角落里。对，所以我们有点像杰克和吉尔式的卫浴间布局。
So- Oh, I had to go down the hall. I had a little shower caddy and I had to walk to a like community shower. I mean, it was a girl's dorm. But you know. I'm not going to lie. I kind of picked my college because- Of the bathrooms.
所以——哦，我得去走廊尽头。我拎着一个小洗漱筐，走到公共浴室去。我的意思是，那是女生宿舍。不过你知道的。我实话实说。我挑大学某种程度上就是因为——因为浴室。
Because of the dorm room situation, like slightly. I loved my school. I went to Truman State in rural Missouri. It was amazing. I loved it there. But the dorms at the time, this was a little rare, you had like two bedrooms separated by a bathroom. So it would be four girls sharing one bathroom.
因为宿舍的情况，稍微有一点。我爱我的学校。我去了密苏里州乡村的杜鲁门州立大学。太棒了。我很喜欢那儿。但当时的宿舍挺少见的，你会有两个卧室中间隔着一个浴室。所以会是四个女生共用一个浴室。
But guess what? What? The dorm room on the other side of our bathroom had an issue. It was like really smelly. Like maybe it smelled like maybe an animal died in the wall. Ooh, gross. It was so gross. So they didn't put anyone in there.
但你猜怎么着？什么？我们浴室另一侧的那间宿舍出了点问题。里面味道特别冲。就好像，闻起来像是有什么动物死在墙里面了。噢，太恶心了。简直恶心透顶。所以他们没有安排任何人住进去。
So we were just two girls with one bathroom. So it was only two of us, you know, me and my roommate shared. And at first my roommate and I were like, what if we open the window and air it out? We could just make that like a living room. We were all excited. Okay, we tried. We could not get rid of that smell. Did you report it?
于是我们俩就成了两个女生独占一个浴室。所以真的只有我们俩，你知道的，我和室友共用。起初我和室友还在想，如果我们把窗户打开通通风呢？我们完全可以把那个房间当成客厅。我们当时都兴奋极了。好吧，我们试过了。但我们根本去不掉那个味道。你们上报了吗？
Yeah. And they could never get rid of the smell. It just stayed empty. Luckily, if you kept the bathroom door shut to that room, it didn't come our way. Yeah. I don't know what happened in there. But as a result, we got a pretty private bathroom. That's amazing.
报了。但他们怎么也去不掉那个味道。它就一直空着。幸运的是，只要把通往那个房间的浴室门关上，味道就不会飘到我们这边来。对。我不知道里面到底发生了什么。不过结果就是，我们拥有了一个相当私密的浴室。太棒了。
Yeah. I went to Baylor University. I loved my dorm room. Collins. There were Collins girls out there, but I shared one room. We had the shower down the hall and my roommate's name was also Angela. Oh. So everyone in college called me Kinsey.
对。我上的是贝勒大学。我可太喜欢我的宿舍了。柯林斯宿舍。那里的柯林斯女孩们懂的，不过我住的是单间。我们得去走廊尽头洗澡，而且我室友的名字也叫安吉拉。哦。所以大学里每个人都叫我金西。
And I still to this day know anyone who knew me in college because all my messages like on voicemail, like my husband can always tell because they're like, Kinsey, what's up? No one knew my name was Angela. I think a lot of people just thought my name was Kinsey. My roommate, I loved her. Her name was TJ and she came from such a small town in Iowa that you could just write her name and then the city and state and zip code. You did not have to write her house number or her street.
直到今天，只要有人在大学认识我，我一听就知道了，因为所有语音留言之类的，比如我丈夫总是能分得清，因为他们会说：“金西，最近怎么样？”根本没人知道我叫安吉拉。我想很多人大概以为我的名字就叫金西。我的室友，我可太喜欢她了。她叫TJ，她来自爱荷华州的一个小镇，只要写上她的名字，再加上城市、州和邮政编码就行了。你根本不用写她的门牌号或街道。
That's my hometown, Jenna. And she would get mail. I found that so cool that I would write her letters on break and then we'd come back and be like, did you get it? She'd be like, oh yeah. And I went home with her once to like, you know, visit and it was amazing. Like she was the coolest. That was my hometown.
那是我的家乡，珍娜。她会收到信件。我觉得这太酷了，放假时我会给她写信，然后我们回学校后就会问，你收到了吗？她会说，哦，对呀。我有一次还跟她一起回她家去，你知道的，去作客，那感觉太棒了。她简直酷毙了。那是我的家乡。
I mean, we didn't have to dial a full phone number, just four digits and you could get anyone in town. Wow. I know. Crazy times. But I guess to wrap that up, I'll just say I had a loft. You had a loft. So Michael had a point.
我是说，我们甚至都不用拨完整的电话号码，只要四位数字就能联系到镇上的任何人。哇。我知道。真是疯狂的年代。不过我想总结一下，我就是说我有阁楼。你有阁楼。所以迈克尔说得有道理。
He did. I want to point out in this scene at three minutes, 55 seconds, you can see the latest fish in the fish bowl. It's an all black goldfish. This is going to be the last fish of Michael Scott Paper Company. Yeah, why didn't Michael bring the fish to his office? I don't know. That's a really good point, Angela.
确实。我想指出在这场戏3分55秒的时候，你能看到鱼缸里的最新鱼。那是一条全黑的金鱼。这将是迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司的最后一条鱼了。对啊，为什么迈克尔不把鱼带到他的办公室呢？我不知道。这真是个好问题，安吉拉。
What happened? Yeah. Well, Randy told us in real life, this fish went to his assistant Jackie and it lived on her desk for two years. He said the fish kept getting bigger and bigger and they had to get bigger fish bowls to accommodate it. But she took very, very good care of it. Well I have appreciated your documentation of the fish every week.
怎么回事？好吧，兰迪告诉我们，在现实生活中，这条鱼被送给了他的助理杰基，并在她的办公桌上活了两年。他说鱼越长越大，他们不得不换更大的鱼缸来容纳它。不过她把鱼照顾得非常好。好吧，我很欣赏你每周对鱼的记录。
I feel like it was your plant. It was my plant at reception. It was. Well, it's over. That's your last fish breakdown. Back upstairs on Dunder Mifflin, special guests coming in, David Wallace, to check in on things because they keep losing clients. And Charles seems very enamored with David Wallace, wants to impress him.
我觉得它就像是你的植物。它曾是我在前台的植物。确实如此。好吧，它结束了。这是你最后一次鱼类的盘点分析。镜头回到邓德米夫林楼上，特别嘉宾大卫·华莱士来视察情况了，因为他们一直在失去客户。而查尔斯看起来对大卫·华莱士迷恋得不行，一心想给他留下好印象。
Yeah, we had a fan catch in this, which delighted me. Many people wrote in to say, does Idris Elba break character at five minutes 25 seconds when Kevin says hi to David Wallace? I totally saw that too and he does. He does. He does. Totally. I wondered if that was like an addition because everyone, you know, David is trying to get
对，我们在这一段里发现了一个粉丝捕捉到的穿帮镜头，这让我乐坏了。很多人写信来问，当凯文向大卫·华莱士打招呼时，伊德瑞斯·艾尔巴是不是在5分25秒时笑场了？我完全也看到了，他确实笑场了。他真的笑场了。确实如此。完全笑场了。我当时还在想，这算不算是临时加的，因为每个人，你知道的，大卫正试图把
things going but people keep interrupting just to say hi. Yeah. And Kevin has this late breaking hello, very funny. Idris totally broke character. 100%. If you want to see just a glimmer of the charming man that Idris Elba is, you can see it at five minutes, 24 seconds, because he gets a little smiley twinkle in his eye. After Charles greets David Wallace, Jim just watches this whole thing play out.
事情理出头绪，但大家总是不停地打断他，只为了打个招呼。对。而且凯文这个迟来的问候，超级搞笑。伊德瑞斯绝对笑场了。百分之百。如果你想一睹伊德瑞斯·艾尔巴那迷人男士的风采，你在5分24秒就能看到，因为他的眼睛里闪烁着一丝微笑的光芒。在查尔斯迎接了大卫·华莱士之后，吉姆就静静地看着这一切发生。
And then there is a cutaway to him in the break room and he's just doing a kissy noises. Right? Well, that was not in the script. That must have happened on the day. In the script, it's a talking head and this was Jim's scripted line. So OMG, turns out Charles Miner is a huge kiss-ass. Mmm. But I kind of liked that it was just the kissing noise.
然后镜头切到了他在茶水间的画面，他正对着空气发出送飞吻的声音。对吧？好吧，这可不是剧本里有的。这肯定是在拍摄当天现场发挥的。在剧本里，这是一个独白镜头，而这是吉姆剧本里的台词。所以，天哪，原来查尔斯·迈纳是个彻头彻尾的马屁精。嗯。不过我倒挺喜欢只有亲吻声音这个处理的。
I did too. Right? He just was like, we know what's happening here. Well, David is telling everyone that although Michael Scott Paper Company has stolen some clients, he believes it's just a temporary setback, but this brings on some real Phyllis sass. Yeah. She's like, perhaps if you had returned Michael's phone calls, this would have never happened.
我也是。对吧？他当时就像是在说，我们都很清楚这里在发生什么。好吧，大卫正在告诉大家，尽管迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司偷走了一些客户，但他相信这只是暂时的挫折，不过这话却引发了菲莉丝的一波强势输出。对啊。她说，也许如果你当初回一下迈克尔的电话，这一切就根本不会发生了。
What you need to know about Phyllis is that she's already pissed off because of the expense reports. So she is not mincing her words. And then David is going to invite Jim to join him and Charles in the conference room. And Charles is like, hold up, Dwight's been my guy, Jim not living up to his potential. And David's like, I'm surprised by that. Oh my gosh, it's so amazing. So good.
关于菲莉丝，你需要了解的是，她因为费用报销单的事本来就已经一肚子火了。所以她说话根本毫不留情。然后大卫邀请吉姆加入他和查尔斯在会议室的谈话。查尔斯则说，等等，德怀特才是我的得力干将，吉姆并没有发挥出他的潜力。大卫却说，我很惊讶你会这么说。噢天哪，太精彩了。太棒了。
And it plays out so well because David says, let's invite them both. I think we should take a break because when we come back, I mean, there's some serious accounting issues over at Michael Scott Paper Company. Oh my gosh, it made me laugh out loud. All right. We will take a break. We'll be back. Well, we are back and the Michael Scott Paper Company has decided to go speak to an accountant
而且这段戏效果出奇的好，因为大卫说，把他们俩都叫进来吧。我想我们该休息一下了，因为等我们回来时，我的意思是，迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司那边可有些严重的财务问题。天哪，把我笑得前俯后仰的。好吧。我们要休息一下。马上回来。好吧，我们回来了，迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司决定去找一位会计师
to see if they can hire a delivery guy. But they can't. Not only can they not afford a delivery guy. They are bleeding money. Their prices are putting them out of business. It's not looking good for Michael Scott Paper Company. It's not. It's also not looking great for Ryan because he had calculated all this.
看看他们能不能雇一个送货员。但他们雇不起。他们不仅雇不起送货员。而且他们正在严重亏损。他们的定价让他们濒临倒闭。迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司的情况看起来很不妙。确实不妙。瑞恩的情况看起来也不是很好，因为他之前把这些全算过一遍。
Yes. But he used a fixed cost formula and he should have used a variable cost formula. He seems a little confused by those terms. I looked it up. I wrote up a whole thing about it and I still don't understand it. So. Oh my gosh. I mean, I think if I think really, really hard, I can get there.
对。但他用的是固定成本公式，而他本该用变动成本公式的。他似乎对这些术语有点糊涂。我特意去查了。我写了一整篇文章来研究它，结果我还是没搞懂。所以。天哪。我的天，我觉得如果我绞尽脑汁、拼命去想，我大概能理清头绪。
Okay. Are we going to have to think hard right now? I don't know. I mean, I can just skip it. Do we want to think hard or no? Well, let's give it a try. All right. All right, everybody.
好吧。我们现在非得绞尽脑汁地思考吗？我不知道。我的意思是，我可以跳过不谈。我们是想动脑筋思考呢，还是算了吧？好吧，那我们试一试。好吧。好吧，各位。
Ready? Variable and fixed costs are the two main types of costs that a company incurs. Okay. Variable costs are volume related. Okay. Variable costs vary with the amount of products you're making. Okay. While fixed costs are time related, they stay consistent.
准备好了吗？变动成本和固定成本是一家公司产生的两类主要成本。好。变动成本是与业务量相关的。好。变动成本会随着你生产的产品数量而变化。好。而固定成本是与时间相关的，它们保持不变。
It doesn't matter how much stuff you make. Just to keep the lights on, these are your fixed costs. So for example, your rent on your office space, that isn't going to change month to month. If you make five widgets or 500 widgets, your rent is the same. Right. But what if you have an employee that gets injured and now you have to file workman's comp and you're paying all this extra stuff? Well, that would go under your variable costs.
无论你生产多少东西，这都没关系。仅仅为了维持开门营业，这些就是你的固定成本。所以，举个例子，你办公室的空间租金，这个不会月复一月地发生变化。无论你生产5个小物件还是500个小物件，你的租金都是一样的。没错。但是，如果你有一个员工受伤了，现在你必须申请工伤赔偿，还要支付所有这些额外的费用呢？哦，那就会归入你的变动成本。
Variable costs. I'm with you. Oh my gosh. Our brains are working. We're doing it. So the more fixed costs you have, the more revenue your company needs in order to break even. So that makes sense.
变动成本。我跟上你的思路了。天哪。我们的脑子开始运转了。我们做到了。所以，你的固定成本越高，你的公司就需要越多的营业收入才能达到收支平衡。所以这说得通。
The more overhead you have, the more you have to make. I mean, Ryan went to business school. He was the vice president of the Northeast region or whatever. I know. Now if you produce 500 widgets, that's going to really offset your fixed cost, right? Okay. But if you produce your 500 widgets for not enough money, you're never going to cover your fixed costs.
你的日常开销越大，你必须赚的钱就越多。我的意思是，瑞恩可是商学院毕业的。他曾担任过东北地区的副总裁什么的。我懂。现在，如果你生产500个小物件，那将极大地抵消你的固定成本，对吧？好。但如果你生产这500个小物件的售价不够高，你将永远无法涵盖你的固定成本。
Got it. And then your variable costs are going to put you out of business as well. I don't know. I think we got it. Kind of. The point is they cannot afford a delivery driver. Ryan's accounting was horrible and they are going out of business because their prices are too low.
懂了。然后你的变动成本也会最终拖垮你的公司。我不知道。我觉得我们弄懂了。差不多吧。重点是他们根本请不起送货司机。瑞恩的财务计算简直一团糟，而且由于他们的定价太低，他们正面临倒闭。
Yes. And all of this information was delivered by a delightful guest star playing the accountant Ty Platt and that person is Kurt Scholar. He is a seasoned improvisational performer. He's done a ton of television. Angela, I believe you knew him from your improv days. I did. When I were both at iOS, he is so smart and quick and funny, really talented guy.
是的。所有这些信息都是由一位可爱的客串演员带来的，他饰演会计师泰·普拉特，那位演员就是库尔特·施拉勒。他是一位经验丰富的即兴表演艺术家。他演过大量的电视剧。安吉拉，我记得你在即兴表演时期就认识他。我确实认识。当时我们都在iO剧团，他既聪明又敏捷还很有趣，真的是个很有才华的人。
Again, we were so lucky to get such great guest stars on our show. Well, you know, on his computer, when Michael is like crunch those numbers again, and he hits one button and nothing changes, well, nothing could ever change because that was a fakie spreadsheet on the computer. It was made by our graphics designer, Michael Marcus. I said earlier that Michael also made the decal for the side of the van. And it just got me thinking, if you are a graphics designer, you can work for a TV show.
同样，我们真的很幸运能在我们的剧里请到这么棒的客串演员。对了，你知道的，在电脑前，当迈克尔说“重新计算一下那些数字”时，他按了一个按钮却什么都没变，嗯，什么都不可能会变，因为那只是电脑上的一个假电子表格。那是我们的平面设计师迈克尔·马库斯制作的。我之前说过，迈克尔还制作了货车车身上的贴花。这让我不禁联想到，如果你是一名平面设计师，你完全可以为电视剧工作。
TV shows have a graphics designer on their team. Yeah. That's so cool. I know. He would make logos and all kinds of things for us when we needed fakie signs and props and things. We needed things like that almost weekly. Yes.
电视剧的团队里都有平面设计师。对。太酷了。我知道。每当我们需要假的标牌、道具之类的时候，他就会为我们制作标志和各种各样的东西。我们几乎每周都需要这类东西。是的。
So he would work with Phil Shea to design these things and with Michael Gelenberg, our production designer. I have to share with you guys, after the scene, Ryan was going to have a complete meltdown. It's in the deleted scenes. It is so crazy. But it's like Ryan is faced with the fact that, A, this new business that he was, I guess, optimistic about is going out of business, but also the fact that he crunched the numbers and he was wrong, and he is actually not very good at being a businessman.
所以他会与菲尔·谢伊合作设计这些东西，还会与我们的制作设计师迈克尔·盖伦伯格合作。我必须跟你们分享一件事，在这场戏之后，瑞恩本该有一场彻底的情绪崩溃。这段被收录在删减片段里。实在是太疯狂了。但这就好像瑞恩面对这样一个事实：A，这个他曾经、我猜是抱着乐观态度的全新业务即将倒闭；但同时还有这样一个事实，那就是他自己算过账却算错了，而且他其实并不擅长当个商人。
But he loses it, Jenna. It's in the deleted scenes on the DVD. He throws those cheese balls, he opens it up, and he just starts throwing them everywhere. I am talking everywhere. He dumps the entire container and is yelling, and Michael's just watching it all happen. Is Pam there? Pam leaves. Oh.
但他彻底崩溃了，珍娜。它就在DVD的删减片段里。他把那些起司球扔了出去，把包装打开，开始到处乱扔。我是说到处都是。他把整整一容器的起司球都倒了出来，还在大喊大叫，而迈克尔就站在一旁看着这一切发生。帕姆在场吗？帕姆已经走了。哦。
He starts throwing things. She leaves. I don't remember this. Yeah. Isn't that crazy? Yes. I totally get why this one didn't make it in because it was kind of over the top. Like Ryan trashes their office.
他开始扔东西。她离开了。我不记得这个了。是啊。是不是很疯狂？是的。我完全明白为什么这一段没能剪进正片里，因为它有点太夸张了。比如莱恩把他们的办公室砸了个稀巴烂。
Well, what actually made it in the episode is that they just returned, they're very just down in the dumps, and Michael starts calling clients and saying, you know what, actually, we need you to give us more money. Could you imagine? No. Could you imagine if you bought something from a company and then they called you later in the day and said, will you pay me more for that because I'm actually going out of business?
嗯，真正剪进这一集的内容是，他们刚回来，情绪非常低落，迈克尔开始给客户打电话说，你知道吗，实际上，我们需要你们给我们更多钱。你能想象吗？不。你能想象如果你从一家公司买东西，然后他们那天晚些时候打电话给你说，你能为那个付我更多钱吗，因为我实际上快要倒闭了？
Yeah. That is such a weird phone call. I know. And Pam has that great talking head. She does. She says, when a child gets behind the wheel of a car and crashes into a tree, you don't blame the kid. You blame the 30-year-old woman in the passenger seat who trusted the kid and said, go ahead,
是啊。那真是一个非常奇怪的电话。我知道。帕姆有那段很棒的直面镜头。她确实有。她说，当一个孩子坐上汽车方向盘并撞上一棵树时，你不会责怪这个孩子。你会责怪副驾驶座上信任这个孩子并说，去吧，
drive, kid. Yeah. You got- Something like that. I'm paraphrasing. Yeah. She's like, you got this. You got this, kid.
开吧，孩子。是啊。你得到了——差不多就是这样。我在意译。是啊。她就像是在说，你行的。你行的，孩子。
Yeah. Lady, should we go back up to the conference room for a scene that I couldn't get enough of? I enjoyed the scene so much. You guys know that Jenna and I watched these episodes two to four times before we record. This was a highlight every single time. One of my absolute favorite moments in the entire episode is when Dwight suggests getting all of his bees and putting the bees in the office.
是啊。女士们，我们应该回到会议室去看一个让我看不够的场景吗？我非常喜欢这个场景。你们知道詹娜和我会在录制前把这些集看两到四遍。每一次这都是一个亮点。整集中我绝对最喜欢的时刻之一，就是德怀特建议把他的所有蜜蜂都弄来，然后把蜜蜂放进办公室。
Watch Idris as Charles turn and just look at Dwight as he's giving his bee speech. And going across Idris's face of like, holy crap. Yes. Who have I attached myself to in front of David Wallace? I also love the attention to detail in this scene visually. I don't know if you noticed, but Jim and David Wallace are both wearing blue shirts with kind of blue ties. And on the other side of the table, Dwight and Charles both have on kind of like a white
看伊德里斯饰演查尔斯转过身，看着正在发表蜜蜂演讲的德怀特。伊德里斯脸上掠过那种“天呐”的表情。是的。在大卫·华莱士面前，我都攀附上了什么人啊？我还很喜欢这个场景在视觉上的细节处理。我不知道你们有没有注意到，吉姆和大卫·华莱士都穿着蓝色的衬衫，系着那种蓝色的领带。而在桌子的另一边，德怀特和查尔斯都穿着那种白色
or a light yellow canary yellow. Yeah. Brilliant. Yeah. So cool. It's almost like teams. Yes. They have on their team colors.
或者淡黄色的金丝雀黄。是的。太精彩了。是啊。太酷了。这几乎就像是分队。是的。他们穿着自己团队的队服颜色。
Yes. Also, I noticed in the scene at 8 minutes 56 seconds, a Fiji water bottle. I saw that too. And I thought- Once again with the label turned away from camera. I was like, what is this? What is that? Because it showed up back in Wallace's office. He had a water bottle.
是的。另外，我注意到在8分56秒的场景中，有一瓶斐济水。我也看到了。我以为——标签依然是背对镜头的。当时我想，这是什么？那是什么？因为它又回到了华莱士的办公室。他有一瓶水。
Remember my son did the whole water bottle break down? Yeah. Yeah. Fancy water bottle for David Wallace? I'm going to ask Randy about it. Yeah. What? Why the Fiji water showing up in scenes all the time?
还记得我儿子做的那个矿泉水瓶分析吗？是啊。是啊。大卫·华莱士的高档水瓶？我要去问问兰迪这事。是啊。什么？为什么斐济水总是在场景里出现？
Were they giving us money? No. The label is not facing camera. I know, but everybody knows it's Fiji because they're the square bottle. I'm going to get to the bottom of it. Get to the bottom of it. We haven't seen a lot of Jim and Pam together in this episode. Or in any of these episodes.
他们在给我们赞助费吗？没有。标签没有朝向镜头。我知道，但每个人都知道那是斐济水，因为它们是方形的瓶子。我要打破砂锅问到底。打破砂锅问到底。在这集里我们没怎么看到吉姆和帕姆在一起。或者在任何这些集里。
I know. Yeah. Well, they're working at rival paper companies. I guess so. They do have this great scene in the hallway where Pam tells Jim that they have about a month before they're going to go out of business. And he tells her not to worry, but then his phone starts ringing. Yes.
我知道。是啊。嗯，他们在竞争对手的纸业公司工作。我想是的。他们在走廊里确实有这样一个很棒的场景，帕姆告诉吉姆，他们大约还有一个月的经营时间就要倒闭了。他告诉她不要担心，但随后他的电话开始响了。是的。
I have an audio clip of it. Idiot. Idiot. Idiot. That's Jim's ringtone. Yes. Now, to create the ringtone, they recorded Rain saying idiot, right? And then our post production supervisor, Jake Ost, put it on a loop.
我有一段它的音频剪辑。笨蛋。笨蛋。笨蛋。那是吉姆的手机铃声。是的。为了制作这个铃声，他们录下了雷恩说“笨蛋”的声音，对吧？然后我们的后期制作主管杰克·奥斯特把它做成了循环播放。
And then our sound engineer actually put a speaker on the set next to us. It was not actually coming from the phone. In post production, they put a filter on the sound to make it sound like it was coming from the phone. But that was like a whole fake ringtone thing we had to set up. So nowadays, obviously, you can get customized ringtones for your phones and you can actually get this ringtone over on OfficeTally.com. No way.
然后我们的音响工程师实际上在我们旁边的工作室布景里放了一个扬声器。声音其实不是从电话里传出来的。在后期制作中，他们在声音上加了一个滤镜，让它听起来像是从电话里传出来的。但那就像是我们必须设置的整个假铃声。所以现在，很明显，你可以为你的手机获取自定义铃声，你实际上可以在OfficeTally.com上获取这个铃声。不会吧。
Yeah. I love that. Well, when I watched this moment, I started laughing so hard because I remembered years later into the show, Kenneth Paul, who did my makeup, who also did Rain Wilson's makeup, had Rain do like a voice memo and he made that his ringtone. So Kenneth Paul's ringtone was Rain Wilson doing this, brrrring, ring, ring. It was so annoying. And whenever KP's phone would ring, I'd be like, oh my God, Kenneth Paul.
是啊。我太喜欢了。嗯，当我看到这一刻时，我笑得前仰后合，因为我记起多年后在这部剧里，为我化妆的肯尼思·保罗，他也为雷恩·威尔逊化过妆，让雷恩录了一个语音备忘录，并把它做成了他的铃声。所以肯尼思·保罗的铃声就是雷恩·威尔逊发出这种声音，嘟——铃，铃，铃。太烦人了。每当KP的电话响起时，我就会想，哦天哪，肯尼思·保罗。
Have you ever had a personalized ringtone? I haven't. Me either. Maybe we should. Should we make it the Office Ladies theme as our ringtone or is that too narcissistic? Okay. I was going to just have Keanu Reeves maybe be my ringtone. Like you know what?
你用过个性化铃声吗？我没有。我也没有。也许我们应该用。我们应该把《办公室女士》的主题曲作为我们的铃声，还是这太自恋了？好吧。我本来打算让基努·里维斯当我的铃声来着。就像你知道的什么？
What if when I'm fainting with excitement over this idea. What if my ringtone is just surfs up, bruh? What if that or my ringtone could be I Know Kung Fu? All I know for certain is that when we're finished recording today, I will be looking up Keanu ringtones. Yes. This I know for sure. Okay.
如果我对这个想法兴奋得快要晕过去时呢。如果我的铃声只是“冲浪去吧，兄弟”呢？如果那样，或者我的铃声可以是“我会功夫”呢？我唯一能确定的是，当我们今天录制结束时，我会去搜基努的铃声。是的。这一点我很确定。好吧。
Where are we? We're back down in Michael Scott Paper Company and Michael is on the floor. They're so mopey. They're so mopey. Michael says he always thought that the day Steve Martin died would be the worst day of his life, but he was wrong because it's this. Pam's like, you know Steve Martin's not dead. And he's like, I know.
我们在哪？我们回到了迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司，迈克尔正趴在地板上。他们太无精打采了。他们太无精打采了。迈克尔说他一直以为史蒂夫·马丁去世的那天会是他一生中最糟糕的一天，但他错了，因为今天是这天。帕姆说，你知道史蒂夫·马丁没死。而他说，我知道。
I have to say something. Yeah. Have you watched Steve Martin's new show on Hulu Only Murders in the building? I haven't. And so many people are telling me to watch it. I know you love it. Okay. Absolutely loved it.
我必须说点什么。是啊。你看过史蒂夫·马丁在Hulu上的新剧《大楼里只有谋杀》吗？我没看。有好多人都在劝我看。我知道你很喜欢它。好吧。绝对超喜欢。
Amy Ryan is on it. She even talked about it on our podcast. Yes. She's so good. You know, the premise of the show is that this guy in their building named Tim Kono has been murdered and these three residents come together to try to solve the crime while doing a podcast about it. In episode two of Only Murders in the Building, this show that Steve Martin is in that he
艾米·瑞安参演了。她甚至在我们的播客里谈过这事。是的。她太棒了。你知道的，这部剧的前提是，他们大楼里的一个名叫蒂姆·科诺的家伙被谋杀了，这三个居民聚在一起试图破案，同时还做了一个关于此事的播客。在《大楼里只有谋杀》的第二集里，史蒂夫·马丁参演并由他
created, I want you to hear what they say. Okay. What if Tim was a dick? That's a definite angle. I mean, I wouldn't want him to be dickier than Steve Carell in the office. I still care if Steve Carell in the office got murdered or what are I thinking, thinking, visualizing this system? We need to find someone who knew him.
创作的这部剧，我想让你听听他们是怎么说的。好吧。万一蒂姆是个混蛋呢？那绝对是一个角度。我的意思是，我可不希望他比《办公室》里的史蒂夫·卡瑞尔更混蛋。我还在乎《办公室》里的史蒂夫·卡瑞尔被谋杀了吗，或者我在想什么，在脑海里勾勒这个系统？我们需要找一个认识他的人。
How about that for full circle? Yeah. Pretty amazing. So Steve Carell references Steve Martin and then on Steve Martin's show they reference Steve Carell. Yes. Okay. I think there's, we need to discuss there's some big revelations that happen in this scene.
这算不算是形成了一个完美的闭环？是啊。太神奇了。所以史蒂夫·卡瑞尔引用了史蒂夫·马丁的话，然后在史蒂夫·马丁的剧里他们又引用了史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。是的。好吧。我认为有，我们需要讨论一下，这个场景中发生了一些重大的大揭秘。
I was going to say Pam says that she's applied for a job at Target Old Navy in Walmart and none of them even called her in for an interview. Ryan confesses that he didn't even go to Thailand. No, just Fort Lauderdale. That is so perfect. I thought that was so brilliant. Of course Ryan lied about going to Thailand. Of course.
我正要说帕姆说她申请了塔吉特、老海军和沃尔玛的工作，他们甚至都没有叫她去面试。莱恩承认他根本没去过泰国。不，只是劳德代尔堡。太完美了。我觉得这太妙了。莱恩当然对去泰国这件事撒了谎。当然。
And this is when Michael pretends that he loves Pad Thai because Ryan said there was a great Pad Thai place in Fort Lauderdale, but then Ryan's like, you've never had Pad Thai. Michael's like, I haven't done a lot of things. This was a fan catch by Ella W and Abby W. What'd you catch? The W's. What'd you catch?
这就是迈克尔假装他喜欢泰式炒河粉的时候，因为莱恩说劳德代尔堡有一家很棒的泰式炒河粉店，但随后莱恩却说，你根本没吃过泰式炒河粉。迈克尔说，我有很多事都没做过。这是由粉丝埃拉·W和艾比·W发现的。你们发现了什么？姓W的这两位。你们发现了什么？
They said in diversity day, Michael wishes aloud that he had some Pad Thai because he loves Pad Thai. Oh my gosh. Great catch. So they wondered, has Michael been telling people that he loves Pad Thai for years and he's still never tried it? That's also. It's possible.
他们说在多元化日那一集里，迈克尔大声许愿说他想吃点泰式炒河粉，因为他爱吃泰式炒河粉。哦天哪。好发现。所以他们在想，难道迈克尔多年来一直在告诉别人他爱吃泰式炒河粉，但他却从来没尝过？这也是。有可能的。
It's also believable that he thinks that maybe it makes him seem well traveled or something. Yeah. Right? Jenna, after the scene, the expense report deleted runner would have continued and he is determined to get an extension on his expense reports and goes to talk to Angela. These expenses are legitimate. Which I denied. Right.
也有可能他认为这或许能让自己显得见多识广什么的。是啊。对吧？詹娜，在这场戏之后，关于报销单被删减掉的支线本来会继续，他决心要让自己的报销单宽限一段时间，于是去找安吉拉。这些费用都是合法的。我拒绝了。对的。
Would you please, respectively, reconsider these? Why would I do that? Because of our history. Both romantic and thrace sexual. Twice. Re-submit with proof of business. Names of who you were with, what you talked about, phone numbers I can call to verify. You get a two hour extension based on our history.
你能不能，恕我直言，重新考虑一下？我为什么要这么做？因为我们的过去。既有浪漫的，也有瑟瑟的。两次。请重新提交业务证明。和你在一起的人的名字，你们谈论过的话题，我可以打电话核实的电话号码。根据我们的过去，我给你宽限两个小时。
Righto. Then we're even. Yeah. Wow. I know. Hmm. Scandalous. Scandalous exchange.
好吧。那我们就两清了。是啊。哇。我知道。嗯。丑闻。丑闻般的对话。
So yes, Angela's going to give Andy a two hour extension. What is he going to do with that? You'll see. Okay. Oh, I'm so glad. I have the clip. I'm glad that pays off. Oh, I'm very sad this runner was deleted.
所以是的，安吉拉要给安迪宽限两个小时。他要用这个时间做什么？你们会看到的。好吧。哦，我太高兴了。我有这段剪辑。我很高兴这个支线有了回报。哦，这个支线被删了，我很难过。
I know. It was really fun. Now we're going to find out that Dunder Mifflin is going to offer Michael Scott Paper Company a buyout. Yes. So Jim is going to go in to Michael Scott Paper Company and give them this news. And Michael is like, what? Why would they want to do that?
我知道。真的很有趣。现在我们要发现，邓德米夫林要向迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司提出收购。是的。所以吉姆要去迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司把这个消息告诉他们。迈克尔说，什么？他们为什么想这么做？
We're totally like. And Jim's like. I got it. I got it. But once I hear it, I can't unhear it. So don't say it. So Michael gets it. Steve has another one of those amazing moments where he comes to a realization very slowly.
我们完全就像。吉姆说。我懂了。我懂了。但一旦我听到了，我就没法假装没听过。所以别说出来。所以迈克尔懂了。史蒂夫又有那种绝妙的时刻，他非常缓慢地反应过来。
The three of them are going to go upstairs now to meet. And Ryan and Pam are like, Michael, you cannot say that we are broke. You cannot do it. Are we clear? We are not going to mention that we are broke. And he's like, I got it. I got it. They get in the elevator, the doors open on the next floor and he's like, I don't got
他们三个现在要上楼去开会了。然后莱恩和帕姆说，迈克尔，你绝对不能说我们破产了。你绝对不能说。听清楚了吗？我们绝不能提我们破产的事。他说，我懂了。我懂了。他们走进电梯，下一层的门开了，他说，我没
it. I can't do it. I loved it so much. It made me laugh out loud. That's a whole fake elevator, as everyone knows. We got in the elevator, the guy with the pulleys pulled the rope, pulled the rope, shut the doors, and then we relocated to a completely different building to the Dunder Mifflin elevator. And we got out and it is seamless.
懂。我做不到。我太喜欢了。这让我大声笑了出来。如大家所知，那是整个一个假电梯。我们走进电梯，拉滑轮的家伙拉动绳子，拉动绳子，关上门，然后我们转移到了一栋完全不同的建筑里，来到了邓德米夫林的电梯里。我们走出去，衔接得天衣无缝。
It looks so good. Oh, that's funny. And then we walk in and Michael has his line that I have seen quoted so many times where he says, well, well, well, how the turntables. Okay. I had to know how that was scripted. So I went to the shooting draft and that line is not in the script. Oh my gosh.
看起来太棒了。哦，太搞笑啦。然后我们走进去，迈克尔说出了那句我看到过无数次被引用的台词，他说，哟，哟，哟，时水轮转。好吧。我必须知道这段台词原本是怎么写的。所以我去查了拍摄剧本，那句台词根本不在剧本里。哦天哪。
We got a fan question about that. Yeah. I don't know if it was pitched on the fly. You know how sometimes writers would have some pitches. Or if Steve improvised it, I don't know. But in the script, this is what it said, well, well, well, oh, how the meteors fallen. And I love the turntables so much better. Turntables is so funny.
我们为此收到了一个粉丝提问。是啊。我不知道这是不是现场即兴发挥的。你知道编剧有时会有一些即兴点子。或者如果是史蒂夫即兴发挥的，我不知道。但在剧本里，原话是这样的，哟，哟，哟，哦，流星是怎么坠落的。我还是觉得“时水轮转”好得多。转盘太搞笑了。
I know. Because Michael gets all of his phrases slightly off and Michael, you know what? I can relate to that. And you still sell. Friday. Friday. For years, I've been saying Friday. I've been saying lots of things.
我知道。因为迈克尔把所有的成语都用得有点走样，而迈克尔，你知道吗？我对此深有同感。而你还在卖。星期五。星期五。多年来，我一直说成星期五。我一直说错很多东西。
I love that when they get into the conference room, Michael immediately rejects their first offer and he says, just give me your second offer. Yeah. And their second offer is a buyout of $12,000. Kelly and Angela are trying to eavesdrop and Kelly has her ear to the door with like a coffee mug. Mindy and I kept laughing. That was so funny.
我太喜欢他们走进会议室时，迈克尔立刻拒绝了他们的第一个报价，他说，直接告诉我你们的第二个报价吧。是啊。他们的第二个报价是一万二千美元的收购费。凯利和安吉拉试图偷听，凯利把耳朵贴在门上，还拿着一个咖啡马克杯。明迪和我一直在笑。太搞笑了。
It was so ridiculous. We're so invested in what Charles is doing. We have to be eavesdropping. And you know, I remember Mindy tried a few different things. In the script, I asked Kelly, what do you hear? And she actually responds and says, the ocean. But in the episode, we have this, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well, well. She was so good at it.
太荒谬了。我们太关注查尔斯在做什么了。我们必须偷听。而且我记得明迪尝试了几种不同的方法。在剧本里，我问凯利，你听到什么了？她实际上回答说，大海。但在正片里，我们有这个，哟，哟，哟，哟，哟，哟，哟，哟，哟。她演得太棒了。
She was doing Charlie Brown's teacher. Right? It was so funny. We were tickled. Michael is going to reject this offer of $12,000. And this is when he is a brilliant negotiator. I could not believe it. Do you see the look on Pam's face?
她当时在模仿查理·布朗的老师。对吧？太搞笑了。我们被逗乐了。迈克尔要拒绝这一万二千美元的报价。这就是他展现出高超谈判技巧的时候。我简直不敢相信。你看到帕姆脸上的表情了吗？
I do. Pam is all of us in this moment. Exactly. So he gets David to give them an offer of $60,000. Yes. He's like, listen, here's how I see it. You're up for approval by the board. And they're probably not going to be too happy that you are losing customers to Michael Scott
我看到了。此刻的帕姆就是我们所有人的真实写照。没错。所以他让大卫给他们开出了六万美元的报价。是的。他说，听着，我是这么看的。你正等待董事会批准。而他们可能不会太高兴，因为你正在把客户流失给迈克尔·斯科特
Paper Company. So you actually need me. Yes. So they say, we'll give you a moment to discuss it. And now we're going to have a scene out at Dwight and Jim's desks, but did you notice behind them? No one is in the conference room and the door is open. It's a total continuity catch.
纸业公司。所以你实际上需要我。是的。于是他们说，我们给你们一点时间讨论一下。现在我们要去德怀特和吉姆的办公桌外拍一场戏，但你们注意到了他们身后吗？会议室里没有人，而且门是开着的。这是一个彻底的连戏失误。
Ryan, Michael, and Pam should have been in the background there and they're not. Oh, good catch. Yeah. But Dwight gets this phone call from a client saying that Michael Scott Paper Company called them and asked them for more money and they'd like to come back to Dunder Mifflin. And Dwight's going to run into the kitchen and tattle. He's going to tell Charles, Michael Scott Paper Company is going broke. And normally Charles would take that information from Dwight and go right into action.
莱恩、迈克尔和帕姆本来应该在那个背景里的，但他们不在。哦，好眼力。是啊。但德怀特接到一个客户的电话，说迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司打电话向他们索要更多钱，他们想回到邓德米夫林。德怀特跑进厨房去打小报告。他要去告诉查尔斯，迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司要破产了。通常情况下，查尔斯会接受德怀特提供的这个情报并立刻采取行动。
But Dwight's been acting so strange to Charles all day and then Jim capitalizes on that. Yeah. He kind of baits Dwight into bringing out his full weirdo by sort of heckling him about his ability to solve cases. And Charles is like, you're both morons, don't go anywhere near the conference room. Here's what I need to bring up about this scene on a practical level. Did you notice where Charles is standing in this scene? By the counter?
但德怀特一整天对查尔斯表现得都太诡异了，然后吉姆就利用了这一点。是的。他有点像在故意挑衅德怀特，通过嘲笑德怀特破案的能力，把他的全套怪咖行径全都逼出来。查尔斯则说，你们俩都是笨蛋，离会议室远点。关于这场戏，我需要从实际层面提出的一点是。你们注意到查尔斯在这场戏里站在哪里了吗？在柜台旁？
Yes. But very close to the fridge. Yeah. And through the entire scene, he's got his Sadakoi steel coffee mug. Yeah. And he's got a full coffee pot. Each hand is holding one of these items. Why did he walk so far away from the coffee maker to put his coffee in his mug?
是的。但离冰箱非常近。是啊。在整场戏里，他手里一直拿着他的Sadakoi不锈钢咖啡马克杯。是啊。手里还端着一整壶咖啡。他两只手各拿着其中一件物品。他为什么离咖啡机走那么远才把咖啡倒进杯子里呢？
Because the coffee maker is over by the door that leads to the office. So this man is saddled with these two coffee items. And I'm just like, why did he drift? In my mind as an actor, I'm having to make up a reason why this happened. So I'm imagining he got the coffee pot and he's starting to pour and he notices something on the fridge. He wants to get a closer look. And then Dwight comes in and he's now stuck with his two coffees.
因为咖啡机在通往办公室的那扇门旁边。所以这个男人手里拖累着这两样咖啡用品。我当时就在想，他为什么走神走得那么远？作为演员，我在脑海里不得不为主持这种事编造一个理由。所以我脑补的画面是，他拿了咖啡壶，正准备倒咖啡，然后他注意到了冰箱上的什么东西。他想凑近仔细看一看。然后德怀特进来了，他现在被他的两杯咖啡给卡住了。
I don't know. It was an odd staging for me. And I became distracted. I loved it like this moment pulled you out for a minute. Like as an actor process, you're like, that makes no sense. I'm like, I need a reason. I need a motivation. Back in the conference room, Michael says no to this very lucrative offer.
我不知道。对我来说这是一个奇怪的舞台调度。我分心了。我喜欢这种感觉，就像这个时刻把你短暂地拉出了戏。就像从演员的处理方式来看，你会觉得，这毫无逻辑。我就想，我需要一个理由。我需要一个动机。回到会议室里，迈克尔对这个非常丰厚的报价说不。
Yeah. And Pam is like, can we have another minute? Yeah. And this is when Michael again makes perfect sense. And he says, what we need are jobs. We don't need a buyout. That money's not going to last forever. We need employment and everyone agrees.
是啊。帕姆说，我们能再要一分钟吗？是啊。这就是迈克尔再次表现得完全合乎逻辑的时候。他说，我们需要的是工作。我们不需要收购。那些钱不会花一辈子的。我们需要的是就业，每个人都表示赞同。
Yes. This is his teach a man to fish moment. Yes. Right. So when they come back in, that's what Michael is going to say. You have to hire all of us back. And also, in addition to jobs, Michael wants his seabring again and his old parking space. But Charles says they don't make seabrings anymore.
是的。这就是他“授人以渔”的时刻。是的。对吧。所以当他们回来时，迈克尔就要这么说了。你们必须把我们所有人都重新雇回去。而且，除了工作之外，迈克尔还想要回他的赛百灵汽车和他原来的停车位。但查尔斯说他们不再生产赛百灵了。
Is that true? Lady, you know, I had to know. Oh, I'm so glad you looked this up because I didn't look it up and it has been bothering me. All right. Charles is wrong. They are still making the seabring. This episode aired April of 2009, according to the internet, they made the Chrysler Seabring
这是真的吗？女士，你知道的，我必须去查证一下。哦，我太高兴你查了这个，因为我没查，这事一直困扰着我。好吧。查尔斯说错了。他们当时还在生产赛百灵。根据互联网上的记录，这一集于2009年4月播出，克莱斯勒生产赛百灵的时间是从
from 1995 to 2010. And in looking up this fact, I ended up watching several seabring commercials over the years. Oh, you really were infested. I think I watched half an hour worth of commercials. Oh, my gosh, they made some really interesting choices in their commercials. But there's one I really needed you to hear. It is from 1995. It's the year the car debuted.
1995年到2010年。为了查证这个事实，我最后看好几个历年的赛百灵广告。哦，你真的是深陷其中了。我想我看了足足半小时的广告。哦，天哪，他们在广告里做了一些非常有趣的抉择。但有一个广告我真的需要你听听。那是1995年的。那是这款车问世的那一年。
Can we please play that seabring commercial? The new Chrysler Seabring was built upon something called the Goldilocks principle. It occurred to us that while most luxury cars were too big, most sport coupes were too small. We wanted the Seabring to be, well, just right. It not only has a sporty 24 valve engine and a race inspired suspension, but it also gives you the luxury of an actual backseat. Which means there's enough room for Goldilocks and three or four of our friends. Okay, I have to say, okay, so Sam is not with us this week.
我们能放一下那个赛百灵广告吗？全新克莱斯勒赛百灵基于所谓的“金发姑娘原则”打造。我们发现，虽然大多数豪华车都太大了，但大多数运动型双门轿跑车又太小了。我们希望赛百灵做到，嗯，恰到好处。它不仅拥有运动型的24气门发动机和赛车灵感的悬挂系统，还能为你提供真正后排座位的奢华体验。这意味着这里有足够的空间容纳金发姑娘和她的三四个朋友。好吧，我必须说，好吧，所以萨姆这周没有和我们在一起。
He's on vacation. Jordan is filling in and it is like laughing. I can see her. I know. Laughing at that commercial. Thank you guys. When watching my half an hour of Chrysler commercials for the Seabring, I'd had a glass of wine.
他在度假。乔丹代班，她笑得前仰后合。我能看见她。我知道。听到那个广告忍不住笑了。谢谢你们，伙计们。当我看了半小时克莱斯勒赛百灵的广告时，我已经喝了一杯红酒。
And when we got to this one, I literally did a spit take. I was like, what? And the whole time the car is driving through the woods. Okay. Oh, because of Goldilocks. And the three bears. But when they were like, to fit a few of her friends, who are these people? That's when Jordan doubled over.
当我们看到这个广告时，我真的喷水了。我当时想，什么？而且整个过程中汽车一直在树林里穿行。好吧。哦，因为金发姑娘。还有三只熊。但当他们说，为了装下她的几个朋友时，这些人都是谁啊？那就是乔丹笑得直不起腰的时候。
Oh my gosh, I had to share that. So yes, they still had the Seabring. They could have given Michael a Seabring in April of 2009. By the way, I want to say, you know, my friend Stacey, who I invented the tan baster with. Yes. She drove a Seabring. Oh. And it was a lovely car.
哦天哪，我一定要分享这个。所以是的，他们当时还有赛百灵。他们本可以在2009年4月给迈克尔一辆赛百灵。顺便说一句，我想说，你知道的，我和我一起发明“助黑剂”的朋友斯黛西。是的。她就开一辆赛百灵。哦。那是一辆很不错的车。
I have to say it was kind of like, they're right. It was a really nice combination of a sporty coupe, but also roomy. But with a comfortable back seat. I don't know. I never sat in the back seat. Well, Goldilocks would have been happy with it. She could have sat back there. Also, since we brought up Jordan, Jordan did our song parody, Total Eclipse of the Fart.
我必须说这有点像，他们说得对。它确实是运动型双门轿跑车和宽敞空间的完美结合。而且后排座椅还很舒适。我不知道。我从来没坐在后排过。好吧，金发姑娘会对它很满意。她可以坐在后排。另外，既然我们提到了乔丹，乔丹创作了我们的歌曲恶搞版《屁的日全食》。
Yes. That was Jordan who was saying that. We're very happy to have you. Thank you for filling in for Sam today. Yes. Sam, I brought cake today. So you missed out on that. I also got it on my sweater as I walked in.
是的。就是乔丹唱的。我们很高兴有你加入。谢谢你今天替班萨姆。是的。萨姆，我今天带了蛋糕。所以你错过了。我进门时它还弄到了我的毛衣上。
Yeah. I noticed it right away when you walked in and I thought, I don't know, it's ketchup or something. You thought I had a messy breakfast. I guess I did. I guess I did. I thought it was leftover maybe from the last time you wore it. No.
是的。你一进来我就注意到了，我还以为，我不知道，是番茄酱什么的。你以为我吃早餐弄得很脏。我想我是。我想我确实是。我以为那是你上次穿它时留下的呢。没有。
What? I wouldn't leave food on my hoodie and hang it back up. If you didn't notice, you might. Have you never not noticed? It's a pretty big mark right on my boob. I love that my husband, though, didn't say a word as I walked out. Josh, come on. All right.
什么？我才不会把食物留在连帽衫上还把它挂回去呢。如果你没注意到，你可能就会。你从来没有没注意到的时候吗？我胸口正中央有一个很大的污渍。不过，我喜欢的是，当我走出去时，我丈夫竟然一句话也没说。乔什，拜访来真的。好吧。
So back to this episode. Would you like to hear how the expense report finished? Yes, please. As in the script, this is where it would have wrapped up Angela and Andy, their final scene about the expense report. And now, with no further, reddit.adoe, my revised expense report. The deadline's passed. What?
所以回到这一集。你们想听听报销单是怎么收尾的吗？好的，请。正如剧本里写的那样，这就是安吉拉和安迪关于报销单的最后一场戏本该结束的地方。现在，废话少说，reddit.adoe，我的修改版报销单。截止日期已经过了。什么？
When? When you were saying reddit.adoe. It's reddit.adoe. I know. I've always been such a fan of it. Oh. Wow. Isn't that so delicious?
什么时候过的？当你一直在说reddit.adoe的时候。那是reddit.adoe。我知道。我一直都是它的超级粉丝。哦。哇。是不是太妙了？
I'm really sad that got cut. Me too. Oh, and as soon as he was like, I just turn around and I don't look at him anymore and he has to walk away. Well, I have some news for Angela. This power that she's had is going to go away because Michael, Pam, and Ryan get their jobs back. Yep.
这段被删了我真的很伤心。我也是。哦，当他一说这个，我就转过身去不再看他，然后他不得不走开。嗯，我有个关于安吉拉的消息。她拥有的这种权力要消失了，因为迈克尔、帕姆和莱恩重新获得了工作。是的。
That's the buyout. The buyout is that they are all now re-employed by Dunder Mifflin. And I guess, is Charles fired? That was never clear to me. No, I don't think he was fired. He's going to show up in company picnic again. Yeah, no. My understanding, and I reread the script.
这就是收购。收购的意思是他们现在都被邓德米夫林重新雇用了。我想，查尔斯被解雇了吗？这对我来说一直不太清楚。不，我不认为他被解雇了。他还会再次出现在公司野餐那一集里。是的，不。我的理解是，我又重读了一遍剧本。
So a sort of what I inferred is that he's just getting reassigned. Well, he's going to be out of Scranton, obviously. But originally, Michael says I want him fired. And David's like, I'm not going to do that, Michael. Yeah. He's not a good employee. He's maybe not a good fit right here in the Scranton branch. But he's going to still have his other branches.
所以根据我的推断，他只是被重新指派了工作。好吧，他显然要离开斯克兰顿了。但最初，迈克尔说我要他被开除。大卫却说，我不会那么做的，迈克尔。是的。他可能不是个好员工。他可能不太适合斯克兰顿分公司这里。但他依然拥有他的其他分公司。
To manage. To manage. To oversee. That's right. That's how I saw it. Okay. Because the whole thing kind of ends with Charles trying to say goodbye. But Michael says, no, no, you're done.
去管理。去监管。没错。我是这么看的。好吧。因为整件事的结尾有点像查尔斯试图道别。但迈克尔说，不，不，你完了。
And that's the same line that Charles said to Michael in two weeks. Oh. So this is some good Michael staff. Yeah. Michael held on to that. He really did. And then there's this talking head by Michael that kind of ends the episode where he's just sort of wrapping up this whole storyline of having had this paper company.
这和两周前查尔斯对迈克尔说的话是一样的。哦。所以这很符合迈克尔的作风。是的。迈克尔把那句话记在心里了。他真的记住了。然后是迈克尔的一段直面镜头，算是为这一集画上了句号，他只是在总结拥有这家纸业公司的整个故事线。
And Randy shared with us that this was added later. It was not in the original script. They even shot it about two weeks after we shot the rest of this episode. Do you want to know what was in the original shooting draft? Yes, please. Well, there were two final goodbyes to Charles that got cut. Any guesses who would want to make sure they said goodbye to Charles, Jenna? I'm imagining it was the ladies who had their ear to the door who fought over a scarf in
兰迪跟我们分享说，这是后来补拍的。原本的剧本里并没有。他们甚至在我们拍完美剧其余部分的剪辑大约两周后才补拍了这个。你们想知道原本的拍摄剧本里有什么吗？好的，请。嗯，本来有两个对查尔斯的最终告别被剪掉了。詹娜，猜猜谁会想要确保他们向查尔斯道别？我猜是那些把耳朵贴在门上、在雨中为了一条围巾争抢的女士们。
the rain. Yes, Angela and Kelly. So in the script, there was this tag. As Charles is leaving, Angela approaches him and she says, it was an honor. And Charles says, okay then. And he leaves. Dwight looks out the window as Kelly waits for Charles sitting on the hood of his car sexily.
是的，安吉拉和凯利。所以在剧本里，有这样一个彩蛋。当查尔斯离开时，安吉拉走近他说，这是我的荣幸。查尔斯说，那就这样吧。然后他离开了。当凯利性感地坐在他的车前盖上等待查尔斯时，德怀特正看着窗外。
Oh my gosh. As Charles approaches, we see Kelly is sitting on the wrong car. She runs over to Charles, but doesn't get there in time. She bangs on the window as he drives off. Charles talking head. Never sleep with coworkers, man. What? Wait, what?
哦天哪。当查尔斯走近时，我们看到凯利坐在了错的车上。她朝查尔斯跑去，但没赶上。当他开车离开时，她拍打着车窗。查尔斯面对镜头说：永远不要和同事睡觉，伙计。什么？等等，什么？
That's what it ended with. Wait. Co-workers? That's what it said. Never sleep with coworkers, man. Okay. What the heck? That was the ending to this episode.
这一集就是这样结束的。等等。同事？上面是这么写的。永远不要和同事睡觉，伙计。好吧。什么鬼？这就是这一集的结局。
Angela walks up to him, says it was an honor. Kelly tries to sit on his car before he leaves. Hmm. I don't know. Wow. I know. I was like, I have to share that. Okay.
安吉拉走过去对他说，这是我的荣幸。凯利在他离开前试图坐在他的车上。嗯。我不知道。哇。我知道。我当时想，我一定要分享这个。好吧。
Well, listen, I'll have you know that in a very early draft, like one of the earliest outlines for this episode, there was another tag. Now this one didn't even make it into the shooting draft. Okay. Cause I don't know about this one. Listen to this. Hey, lady. Where did you find this?
嗯，听着，我要让你们知道，在这集非常早期的草稿中，比如最早的大纲之一里，还有另一个彩蛋。现在这个甚至都没能进入拍摄草稿。好吧。因为我不知道这个。听着这个。嘿，女士。你在哪找到这个的？
Randy Cordray. Oh, Randy. Here's what it would have been. And I am so bummed that we did not get to do this. You were going to see Pam, Michael and Ryan packing up Michael Scott paper company. And before they go, Michael is going to give them each a Scotty, which is the Michael Scott paper company version of a Dundee. Oh, with a little Scotty doc?
兰迪·科德雷。哦，兰迪。原本的剧情是这样的。我真的很遗憾我们没能拍成这个。你会看到帕姆、迈克尔和莱恩在收拾迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的东西。在他们离开之前，迈克尔要送给他们每个人一个“斯科蒂奖杯”，这是迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司版本的“邓迪奖”。哦，带着一个可爱的小斯科蒂狗？
No, no. Cause Michael Scott. I thought, I thought instead of the man with the briefcase, it was a little Scotty dog. I got really excited. It didn't get far enough to know what the statue would be, but they were going to be called Scotty's instead of Dundee's instead of Dundee's. And Ryan was going to win one that said great style and Pam's said boobs. Oh, Michael.
不，不。因为迈克尔·斯科特。我以为，我以为奖杯不是拿公文包的男人，而是一只小斯科蒂狗。我当时可兴奋了。还没推进到知道雕像会是什么样子的地步，但它们将被命名为“斯科蒂奖”，而不是“邓迪奖”。莱恩将赢得一个写着“绝佳品味”的奖，而帕姆的则写着“胸部”。哦，迈克尔。
So good. Pam got a Scotty. Man, I have my Dundee's both my whitest sneakers and my longest engagement. And I so wish I had a Scotty that said boobs. I have my Dundee's right next to my Emmy and my SAG awards. I'm so jealous you have a real Emmy. I know. Angela won an Emmy for the webisodes.
太棒了。帕姆得到了一个斯科蒂奖。天哪，我有我的邓迪奖杯，一个是我的“最白运动鞋”，另一个是我的“最长订婚期”。我多么希望我能有一个写着“胸部”的斯科蒂奖杯啊。我的邓迪奖杯就摆在我的艾美奖和美国演员工会奖旁边。我很嫉妒你有一个真正的艾美奖。我知道。安吉拉凭网络剧赢得了艾美奖。
The accountants. Me and Brian and Oscar won an Emmy. You guys, it was really amazing. But what sits right next to my Emmy that more people want to point out when they come to my house are my two Dundee's tied ass ass and she's kind of a bitch. I've said this before. I am really bummed that I did not win an Emmy for Pam for Pam. I wanted our gal Pam to win that award.
《会计师》。我和布莱恩还有奥斯卡一起赢得了艾美奖。伙计们，这真的很了不起。但当人们来到我家时，比我的艾美奖更想指出、并摆在我艾美奖旁边的是我的两个邓迪奖杯：“烂屁股”和“她有点像个碧池”。我以前说过这个。我真的很遗憾我没有凭帕姆这个角色赢得艾美奖。我希望我们的好姐妹帕姆能赢得那个奖。
I'll tell you what award Jenna wants to win. What? A Tony award. So my plan after my kids are grown, I am going to retire in New York City and I am going to work hard to get myself in a great Broadway show. I'm going to give the performance of my life. I will vote for you even though I'm not a registered Tony voter. Thank you.
我告诉你们詹娜想赢得什么奖。什么奖？托尼奖。所以我的人生规划是，等我的孩子们长大后，我要在纽约市退休，并且我要努力让自己参演一部百老汇大剧。我要奉献出我一生中最好的表演。我会为你投票的，尽管我不是注册托尼奖评委。谢谢你。
And I want to win a Tony. That's the award I want on my shelf more than any other award. I want that for you so desperately. I hope it can happen. I want a Grammy. Ooh, you aren't a singer. I know. Oh, I know.
而且我想赢得一个托尼奖。比起任何其他奖项，那才是我最想放在书架上的奖。我太渴望你能得这个奖了。我希望这能成真。我想要一个格莱美。噢，你又不是歌手。我知道。哦，我懂。
I want a Grammy because guys, Jenna and I recently found out that with our book we'll be doing an audiobook. We're very excited about doing the audiobook and we found out if you really, really crush it, you can get nominated for a Grammy for your audiobook. Amy Poehler got nominated for a Grammy for her audiobook. That's right. Yes, please. That's right.
我想要一个格莱美，因为伙计们，詹娜和我最近发现，我们的书会有有声书版本。我们对制作有声书感到非常兴奋，我们发现如果你真的，真的表现绝佳，你的有声书就能获得格莱美提名。艾米·波勒就曾因她的有声书获得过格莱美提名。没错。是的，请。就是这样。
I want a Grammy. All right, let's get that F in Grammy. Let's get the Grammy and then get you your Tony. We're going to get those awards this year. You get an award and you guys get an award because you're badasses and you get an award and you get an award. Awards all around. Awards everywhere.
我想要一个格莱美。好吧，让我们在格莱美上拿个F。让我们拿下格莱美，然后帮你拿下托尼奖。我们今年就要把这些奖项收入囊中。你得一个奖，你们也得一个奖，因为你们都是狠角色，你得一个奖，你也得一个奖。到处都是奖。到处都是奖杯。
This was a great episode. I'm going to make you a Scotty. Oh, will you? Is it going to be a Scotty dog? What's it going to be? It will be my interpretation of what a Scotty would be and I'm going to make it myself. So get ready for a second grade skill set of art and crafting coming your way. I will treasure it.
这一集太棒了。我要给你做一个斯科蒂奖杯。哦，你会吗？会是一只斯科蒂狗吗？那会是什么样？这将是我对斯科蒂奖杯的演绎，我会亲自制作它。所以准备好迎接小学二年级水平的艺术和手工向你袭来吧。我会好好珍藏的。
I'm going to get out my glue gun. I'm not kidding. I'm going to make this myself. If we gave out awards for our business of office ladies, which is actually... I know what it would be called. Ramblies? Oh, I was going to say... For our company, Ramble.
我要把我的热熔胶枪拿出来。我不是开玩笑。我要亲手做这个。如果我们为我们的《办公室女士》事业颁发奖项的话，这其实是……我知道它会被叫什么。闲聊奖？哦，我本想说……对于我们的公司，闲聊公司。
A lady. Oh, you get a lady. You get a lady. Should we give out ladies? We could give out ladies. Okay. Cassie and Jordan are nodding yes. We'll give out some ladies.
一个女士奖。哦，你得一个女士奖。你得一个女士奖。我们应该颁发女士奖吗？我们可以颁发女士奖。好吧。卡西和乔丹都在点头表示赞同。我们要颁发一些女士奖。
Oh, let's do it. All right. All right. You guys, thank you so much for listening. We just love you all and thank you for sending in your comments and your questions and being here every week with us. We hope you have a great day. We'll see you next week.
哦，我们干吧。好的。好的。伙计们，非常感谢你们的收听。我们爱你们所有人，谢谢你们发来评论和问题，并且每周都陪伴在我们身边。希望你们今天过得愉快。我们下周见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科. 主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium上免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码：OFFICE。这一集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。